ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
TELL GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY DODD THE
RAZA GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROW HERTZBERG HELLO HUESO
HURTADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MITCHELL
MONNING MORLOCK MORALE. NIELSEN
PAN PORTANTINO. RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG MY CASKEY WIENER
WILK. A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED
IN THE PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR HER TADO. AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR BILL CENTER HER TADO.
ALL POWERFUL AND EVER LIVING
SPIRIT WE PRAISE AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENCE AND ACTION
AND OUR WORLD. IN THE MIST OF
CONFLICT AND DIVISION WE KNOW
IT IS YOU TURN OUR MINDS TO
THOUGHTS OF PEACE. YOUR SPIRIT
CHANGES OUR HEARTS. ENEMIES
BEGIN TO SPEAK TO ONE ANOTHER.
THOSE WHO WERE ESTRANGED JOIN
HANDS IN FRIENDSHIP AND NATION
SEEK THE WAY OF PEACE TOGETHER.
YOUR SPIRIT IS AT WORK. WHEN
UNDERSTANDING PUTS AN END TO
STRIFE WHEN HATRED IS QUENCHED
<c.green>Y MERCY AND VENGEANCE GIVES</c>
WAY TO FORGIVENESS. FOR THIS WE
WILL NEVER CEASE TO THANK AND
PRAISE YOU A MAN. REPEAT AFTER
ME I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. AND.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR THERE
ARE NONEMESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE EEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. IN
A BID FOR WHAT PURPOSE THE RISE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS I'D
LIKE TO REMOVE AB FIVE FIFTEEN
BYE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE AT HIS
REQUEST THANK YOU THE DESK WILL
NOTE. SENATOR JONES FOR A
PURPOSE YOU RISE. A BILL FROM
CONSENT IF WE CAN PULL- FILE
ITEM TO THIRTY THREE. WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX BY BIGELOW FROM THE
CONSENT THANK YOU SENATOR JONES
THE DESK WILL NOTE CENTER TO
RUSSELL LIKE TO DO TWO THINGS.
TO PULL ITEM EIGHTY TWO TWO.
WHICH IS AB FOUR EIGHTEEN FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE. AND PULL
ITEM TWO FOUR SIX WHICH IS AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT FROM THE
CONSENT FORM THANK YOU CENTER
DORADO SENATOR PAM THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST
OF THE SOME OF THE COMMITTEE ON
ARTS AND ENTERTAINMENT- AND
MOVE TO PULL AB THIRTY THREE
SIXTY NINE OFF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU CENTER
PANDA JUST WILL NOT CENTER
JACKSON THANK YOU ARE MADAM
PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
TO THIRTY ONE AB THIRTY TO
FIFTY FOUR. FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON ANY OTHER MEMBERS OKAY
VERY GOOD. SENATE MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A- MADAM.
PRESIDENT WOULD LIKE TO GET A
FULL EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
AYE AYE. AB THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
I AM TO FOUR SIX FROM THE
KITCHEN COUNTER. THANK YOU
SENATOR REQUIRE SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO MOVE AB
ONE OH SIX TO THE INACTIVE FILE
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL THE
DEATH WILL NOTE. ANY OTHER
MEMBERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR AUGUST
SEVENTEENTH THROUGH AUGUST
TWENTIETH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED
BY THE MINUTE CLERK. THERE ARE
FOUR AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK AND
THEY WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BELLS OF.
667-323-3263. THIRTY ONE THREE
SEVENTY SIX FOUR THIRTY GIVE
OUR SECRETARY THE SECOND
READING WILL BE DEEMED READ
WE'RE MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS SENATOR WILK. FILE
ITEM. SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT IS A
CONFIRMATION OF- MARVIN KRAKI
TO THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH APPEALS BOARD MR KROPP
HE PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS A
BUSINESS MANAGER AND FINANCIAL
SECRETARY FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. IBEW LOCAL ELEVEN HE
IS A LABOR REPRESENTATIVE ON
THE BOARD HE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST
FIFTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
WELCOME. CENTER HERTZBERG YEAH
I JUST WANT TO JOIN IN ON THE
SUPPORTIVE WITH EVERYBODY
ENERGY I GOT FROM OUR PROPERTY
HE'S A WONDERFUL WONDERFUL
HUMAN BEING AND- BUT I SAW HIS
NAME UP THERE I COULD NOT TO
BUT NOT STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF HIS CONFIRM. TODAY YOU SAID
HERTZBERG. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I
APOLOGIZE CENTER DORADO. YES I
SPENDING STRONG SUPPORT FOR
MARVIN KHAKI ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
OF HIS DEEP DEEP COMMITMENT AND
DEVOTION TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
ON THE JOB WHICH IS ALWAYS
COMMITTED SELF TOO SO I THINK
IT'S A GREAT HONOR TO BE ABLE
TO DO THIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER DRAWS SO MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLE ON
EVERYTHING ONE TIME EVERYTHING
WILL BE PLACED ON CALL TODAY SO
WE DON'T CATCH FOR THE FIRST
TIME WILL CATCH YOU AT THE END.
NO OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON VOLUME SEVENTY EIGHT.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BELL FIVE FOR JUST I
BRADFORD HI CABRERA I CHIANG
FIVE DALLY. HI DODD. I TERRAZZA
HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. GROSS HER. I
HILL I WOULD. FIVE RETARDANT
AYE JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL. I MONNING FIVE
MORLOCK. ZERO NO NIELSEN I PAN
I PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. STERN AMBERG I LIKE
HOW SKI HI WIENER AYE WILK. I
DIDN'T REMOVE THE CALL ITEM A
CENTER WILL. OKAY. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY SAID CONFIRMATION
A MERRY MACOMB IS STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER THIS IS A
REAPPOINTMENT FOR MISS MCCALL
MYSIA SERVICE ROLE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SHE'S WORKED
IN VARIOUS ROLES IN THE OFFICE
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY TWO
PROVIDING LEGAL REPRESENTATION
FOR INDIGENT CRIMINAL
DEFENDANTS SHE WAS APPROVED ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE FIFTH OF
AUGUST I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE. THANK YOU SENATOR WILK
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE CENTER HERTZBERG. OKAY
VERY. ALL RIGHT MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN BY
OUR CHILDREN I ATKINS AYE BATES.
I TELL FIVE FOR JUST I BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO I CHIANG I DALLY
FIVE DOT. HI TERRAZZA I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROW. I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. I HER TADO FIVE JACKSON
I JONES. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S. MITCHELL FIVE
MONNING FIVE MORLOCK MORALE.
NIELSEN I CAN I PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH. I RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER.
STERN NUMBER FIVE WHAT KASKY I
WIENER I WILK HI CYNDER MUSICAL
MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
ONE SENATOR WILL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY ONE IS A
CONFIRMATION A DOCTOR J. KEITH
GILLIS FOR RE APPOINTMENT TO
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION DR ED GILLIS HAS
SERVED ON THE BOARD SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN HE RECENTLY
RETIRED IS NOW DEAN. CURTIS AND
FOR A PROFESSOR EMERITUS OF
FORCE ECONOMICS AT UC BERKELEY
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON AUGUST FIFTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER WELCOME
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEM
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES I TELL FIVE
FORGES FIVE BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I CHIANG FIVE DALLY.
I DON. HI TERRAZZA FIVE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO HI PATADA HI JACKSON I
JONES NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE FIVE
MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL I MONNING
AYE MORLOCK. ZERO NO NIELSEN.
PAN FIVE PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH.
I RUBIO I SKINNER. STERN NUMBER
FIVE FOR CASKEY I WINNER. I
WILK I SENATOR MOVES THE CALL
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY TWO SENATOR WILL. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO WAS A
CONFIRMATION OF THE FOLLOWING
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARD
REQUIREMENTS. MICHAEL JOHNSON
AND DR JOHN PIERRE WALLS TO THE
CENTRAL COAST REGIONAL BOARD.
EDWARD MUSIC AND JANE POWELL TO
THE COLORADO RIVER BASIN BOARD.
DONALD JR DEAN HAD PETER PUMP
FREEZE TO THE LA HEIGHTENED
BOARD KELLY GOT TO THE NORTH
COAST BOARD IN DOCTOR HENRY.
ABER BALOG POLITELY AND ERIC
ANDERSON TO THE SAN DIEGO BOARD
THESE APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON THE
FIFTH OF AUGUST ON THE
UNANIMOUS VOTE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
BILL. MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO-
POINT OUT MICHAEL JOHNSON- AS-
FINE OUTSTANDING INDIVIDUAL
I'VE KNOWN SINCE I WAS BORN
SINCE HIS MOTHER WAS THE MAID
OF HONOR AT MY PARENTS WEDDING
I REGION I'D VOTE. THAT'S
WONDERFUL SENATOR BILL THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES I TELL FIVE
BARGES. I BRADFORD HI CABRERA I
CHIANG I DALY. FIVE DODD I
TORONTO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I
COULD SOLACE. I GROW. I
HERTZBERG I HILL. I WAS SO FIVE
HER TADO FIVE JACKSON I JONES
FIVE LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ.
I MITCHELL. MONNING FIVE
MORLOCK I MORALE. NIELSEN FIVE
PAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. STERN.
AMBERG HI HI FOR CASKEY HI
WIENER AYE WILK HI SENATOR
MUSICAL MOVING TO FOLLOW HIM
EIGHTY SEVEN SENATOR WILK THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN IS A
CONFIRMATION THE FOLLOWING
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARD
APPOINTMENTS. MARK BRADFORD TO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY REGIONAL
BOARD CYNTHIA GOOS MEN
INTERMENT MOON YO'S TO THE LOS
ANGELES BOARD. ALEX HACKER AND
WILLIAM KISSINGER TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY BOARD AND DR TOM
RIVERA AND WILLIAM BROUGH TO
THE SANTA ANA BOARD THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST
TWELFTH TWENTY UNANIMOUS VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
THANK YOU CENTER WILK MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARE TO LETTER I ATKINS
AYE BATES I TELL. FORGES I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG
HI DOLLY I DON. HI THERE I
WASN'T I GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ HI GROSS. I HERTZBERG
HI HELLO I HUESO I HER TADO I
JACKSON HI JONES I LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE. FIVE MELINDA'S I
MITCHELL AYE MONNING FIVE
MORLOCK I MORALE. I NIELSEN I
PAN. I PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER. STERN UMBERG I
PLAY CASKEY I WIENER AYE WILK.
HI SENATOR MOVES THE CALL
MEMBERS MOVING TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR WHAT ONE
MORE TIME THANK YOU MATTER
PRESENT LAST BUT NOT LEAST FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR
ENTERED GUNTHER FOR APPOINTMENT
TO THE WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD SAN FRANCISCO BAY REGION
PRIOR TO HIS RETIREMENT DR GOT
THERE WAS EXECUTIVE COORDINATOR
FOR THE BAY AREA ECO SYSTEMS
CLIMATE CONSORTIUM HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON AUGUST TWELFTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING THEN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. NO BELL.
FORGES BRADFORD HI CABRERA I
CHIANG I DALY. I DODD. HI THERE
I WASN'T. HI GALGIANI I GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO FIVE JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA AYE AYE MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZNO MITCHELL I MONEY
FIVE MORLOCK. ZERO NO NIELSEN
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO. FIVE
ROTH I REVIEW I SKINNER. STERN
NUMBER HI WHAT KIND OF SKI FIVE
WIENER. FIVE WILK HI. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY SENATOR MOVES A
CALL MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE SENATOR MITCHELL.
SENATOR MITCHELL DID YOU WANT
PERCENT FOLLOWED NINETY THREE.
WONDERFUL MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY
FOUR BY SENATOR MITCHELL AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT AND GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE SENATE BILL
THREE SIX FOUR PERTAINS TO THE
NONRESIDENTIAL ACTIVE SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEM TAX EXEMPTION.
THIS BILL IS SIMILAR TO AB ONE
OH FIVE WHICH IS PASSED OFF OUR
FLOOR ON THE TWENTY FIFTH OF
JUNE. TECHNICAL MINUTES WERE
MADE IN THE ASSEMBLY TO ENSURE
THAT THE EXEMPTION PROVIDED BY
THIS BILL DID NOT GO BEYOND
WHAT IS PROVIDED BY CURRENT LAW.
AS A REMINDER. THIS BILL SEEKS
TO PREEMPTIVELY CORRECT THE
UNINTENDED IMPACT OF THE PROP
FIFTEEN SPLIT ROLL INITIATIVE.
IN THE UPCOMING NOVEMBER BALLOT
ON NON RESIDENTIAL SOLAR ENERGY
SYSTEMS IN THE STATE. EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW PROVIDES
EXEMPTION FROM TAXATION TO
NONRESIDENT WRITTEN ON
RESIDENTIAL ACTIVE SOLAR ENERGY
SYSTEMS. INSTALLED OR
CONSTRUCTED BEFORE JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE UNDER THE
NEWLY CONSTRUCTION EXCLUSION
UNTIL SUBSEQUENT CHANGE IN
OWNERSHIP. THE PASSAGE OF PROP
FIFTEEN WOULD RESULT IN THE
REVOCATION OF THIS EXCLUSION
RESULTED IN FULL MARKET VALUE
ASSESSMENT OF NON RESIDENTIAL
SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS. BEGINNING
JANUARY FIRST OF NEXT YEAR.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT NON
RESIDENTIAL ACT OF SOLAR ENERGY
SYSTEMS ARE ALREADY RECEIVING
THE EXISTING LAW EXCLUSION
CONTINUE TO BE EXEMPTED FROM
TAXATION BY RECLASSIFYING THEM
AS PERSONAL PROPERTY. THIS BILL
UTILIZES THE POWERS GRANTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE BY SECTION TWO
OF ARTICLE THIRTEEN OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION THE
CLASSIFY PERSONAL PROPERTY FOR
DIFFERENTIAL TAXATION OR
EXEMPTION WITH A TWO THIRDS
VOTE. THIS BILL BECOMES AN
OPERATIVE IF PROP FIFTEEN IS
NOT APPROVED AT THE STATEWIDE
GENERAL ELECTION PRESERVING
EXISTING LAW EXEMPTION FOR NON
RESIDENTIAL SOLAR ENERGY
GENERATION SYSTEMS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. CENTER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I.
HAVING SERVED AS A TAX
COLLECTOR TREASURER FOR THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE- NOW WAS NOT
THE ASSESSOR BUT I WAS. TRYING
TO DETERMINE HOW THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY WORK. AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL HOW WOULD THE ASSESSOR.
DETERMINE THE AMOUNT OF THE
COSTS THAT WAS ADDED TO THE-
REAL PROPERTY AND THEN. GET YOU
LOOK AT THE OVERALL AMOUNT OF
THE REAL PROPERTY FOR YOUR
ASSESSMENT. AND SO I WAS JUST
CURIOUS ON THE MECHANICS OF HOW
ASSESSORS ARE TO. SEPARATE THE
TWO AND ONE WOULD BE
DEPRECIATING OVER TIME THE
OTHER MIGHT BE APPRECIATING OF
THE OVERTIME WITH LANDED
PROPERTY AYE. SO I WAS JUST
JUST KIND OF TRYING TO THINK OF
THE MECHANICS OF IT ALL I'M
JUST WONDERING. MADAM PRESIDENT
pBE A CLOSE REMARKS JUST TO KIND
OF HELP ME OUT SO I CAN. THE I.
FEEL COMFORTABLE THANK YOU
SENATOR MORLOCK THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT WELCOME
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
SENATOR MITCHELL IN MY CLOTHES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION FROM
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND THIS BILL DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE MECHANICS OF IT SIR
TO BE QUITE HONEST THIS IS
BEING PUT IN PLACE. IN THAT WE
ARE- EXPECTED TO ADJOURN ON
AUGUST THIRTY FIRSTIN THE
EVENT THAT POP FIFTEEN PASSES
NOVEMBER THIRD AND WE'RE NOT IN
SESSION SO THIS IS A PREEMPTIVE
MEASURE TO PREVENT- YOU KNOW
CURRENT LAW FROM NO LONGER
BEING APPLICABLE IF PROP
FIFTEEN PASSES. I FULLY
ANTICIPATE THAT COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S SUCH AS YOU SERVE
WILL THEN HAVE TO GET ME IN THE
PROCESS OF FIGURING OUT HOW TO
OPERATIONALIZE IT DIFFICULT AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT OUR STATE
BILL THAT'S GOING TO THAT LEVEL
OF DETAIL. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL THANK YOU IS THAT YOUR
CLOTHES. I WAS IN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MA'AM. MEMBERS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES NO BELL. FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO I CHIANG
NO DALLY NO DODD. I DURAZO I
GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG I HILL
AYE HUESO. I HER TADO I JACKSON
I JONES NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
FIVE MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL FIVE
MONEY. FIVE MORLOCK NO MORALE
NO NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. HI RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER STERN NUMBER ALL
RIGHT I WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER AYE WILK. HI CENTER
MUSICAL. BUT IN GENERAL THE
SENATE WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO OUR ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE THE PRESIDING
OFFICER HAS TWO BILLS TO BE OUT
OF PRISON ON BEHALF OF TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
TAKE FILE ITEM ONE OH ONE FIRST
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA JUMP TO
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO.
BETTER PRESIDING OFFICERS
PREPARE TO BE A PRESENT ON FILE
ITEM ONE ONE. BED OF SECTARIAN
CAN YOU PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN AND
AFTER LEADING TO BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT.THEIR LABOR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE WHICH
WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET FROM
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
TO JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
SIX FOR THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT L. A. U. S. T.
TO UTILIZE A BEST VALUE BID
EVALUATION AND SELECTION
PROCESS FOR PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS IN EXCESS OF ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. THIS PROCESS
HAS ALLOWED LAUSD TO LOOK AT
BITTERS BASED ON SAFETY
FINANCIAL CONDITIONS INSURANCE
COVERAGE CRIMES AND MISCONDUCT
BONDING SETTLEMENTS AND
JUDGMENTS. UNFORTUNATELY THE
SELECTION OF A BITTER BASED
SOLELY ON PRICE MAY RESULT IN
PROJECT DELAYS AND COST
OVERRUNS. AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE ALLOWS FOR MORE OBJECTIVE
CRITERIA FOR SELECTING BIDDERS
WHICH IS SHOWN TO YIELD
POSITIVE BENEFITS IN SELECTING
QUALIFIED CONTRACTORS. IN
COMPETITIVE PRICES WITH
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN STATE
AND LOCAL FUNDS BEING SPENT ON
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED IT IS
VITAL THAT THE DISTRICT HAS THE
NECESSARY TOOLS. TO REDUCE RISK
AND MAXIMIZE EFFICIENCIES.
EIGHTY NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
EXTENDS L. A. ULYSSES FORTY TO
UTILIZE THE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT METHOD FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS. ALLOWING
THE STATE MORE TIME TO EVALUATE
THE BENEFITS OF THIS MODEL AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE PASSED
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WITH NOTE NOTEBOOKS
AND TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND SIXTY
SIX I VOTE. IT ALSO EARNED
BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
LEYVA MEMBERS. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. LAST CALL
SO. DISCUSS OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. HERE IN C. NINE MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BASS. BELL FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CHIANG
AYE DALLY. DODD FIVE DURAZO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. HELLO
FIVE HUESO. I HER TADO HI
JACKSON. I JONES. LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO
MITCHELL I MONEY FIVE MORE LOCK
NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO HAN I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER STERN. NUMBER FIVE
HI MY COUNTY I WIENER. I WILK
HI ENTER MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ONE FINAL
ITEM ON BEHALF OF THE PRESIDING
OFFICER TODAY AND THAT IS FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO CENTER
LEYVA IS PREPARED TO PRESENT
BETTER SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
REPEAT. ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KALRA AND ACTUALLY INTO
EMPLOYMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON ONCE
AGAIN CENTER LABOR THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
HELLO MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
AGAIN 2% EIGHTY NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN WHICH EXTENDS THE FILING
DEADLINE FOR RETALIATION CLAIMS
WITH THE DIVISION OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT. D. L. S.
C. FROM SIX MONTHS TO ONE YEAR
THIS BILL ALLOWS PREVAILING
EMPLOYEES IN CASES OF
WHISTLEBLOWER RETALIATION
CLAIMS THE ABILITY TO SEEK
ATTORNEYS FEES AND THE LEGAL
PROCESS. RETALIATION IS THE
ONLY PERVASIVE BUT ALSO A
GROWING PROBLEM TO THE CURRENT
POLITICAL CLIMATE SURROUNDING
IMMIGRATION. THE LAST FOUR
YEARS OF AVAILABLE DATA FROM
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IMMIGRATION
RELATED RETALIATION CLAIMS
FILED WITH THE L. L. C.
INCREASED BY NEARLY. TWO
THOUSAND PERCENT. OMITS THE
PANDEMIC ADVOCATES REPORT AN
INCREASE IN CALLS REGARDING
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES AND
WAGE THEFT IN THIS
CLASSIFICATION. IT IS IMPORTANT
IT IS AS IMPORTANT NOW AS EVER
THAT WE ENSURE THAT ALL LEGAL
AND ADMINISTRATIVE AVENUES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR WORKERS WHO COME
FORWARD. THE TWO MAIN BARRIERS
THAT WORKERS FACE AND FILING A
CLAIM ARE DRESSED IN THIS BILL
ONE WORKERS WILL FACE
RETALIATION ESPECIALLY IN
EXTREME FORMS OF TERMINATION OR
VIOLENCE. NEED MORE TIME TO
GATHER THE RESOURCES AND SEEK
ASSISTANCE TO A SIMPLE SIX
MONTH EXTENSION FOR FILING A
WORKER'S RETALIATION CLAIM WILL
GIVE PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSIDER THE FUTURE OF THEIR
LIVELIHOOD. AND THEIR NEXT
STPS FOR RECOURSE AB NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN ALSO BUILT UPON THE
EXISTING ABILITIES FOR COURTS
TO AWARD REASONABLE ATTORNEY'S
FEES TO ATTORNEYS WHO TAKE
THESE CASES ON BEHALF OF
WORKERS. THIS IS NOT A BILL
THAT IS INTENDED TO INCREASE
LITIGATION AS THE OPPOSITION
ARGUES RATHER AB NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
SENSIBLE AND REASONABLE WAY FOR
LOW WAGE WORKERS. TO PURSUE
RECOURSE WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
UNFAIRLY RETALIATED. AGAINST
FOR INVOKING THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
THE LAW. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I'VE- THANK YOU CENTRAL WE
HAVE JUST OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR WE'RE GONNA START OFF
WITH CENTER BRIDGES GOOD
AFTERNOON CENTER. BUT RISK
PRESIDENT. WHEN THIS MATTER
CAME BEFORE JUDICIARY. I ASKED
SOME QUESTIONS. IN MY
UNDERSTANDING THE BILL HASN'T
CHANGED ALL THAT MUCH. BUT ONE
OF THE CONCERNS I HAD IS THAT
WHEN A PLAINTIFF IS ENTITLED TO
ATTORNEY'S FEES IF THEY WIN.
CONVERSELY WHAT A DEFENDANT BE
ABLE TO COLLECT ATTORNEYS FEES
IF THEY WIN MY UNDERSTANDING
THE ANSWER'S NO. THE OTHER
THING IS. I BELIEVE THIS
PROBABLY WILL INCENTIVIZE
LAWSUITS BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTANDING BASED ALSO ON THE
JUDICIARY DISCUSSION. IS THAT
MANY OF THESE CAN BE RESOLVED
OUT OF THE COMMISSION FOR OUT
OF COURT AND WHEN THAT.
APPRECIATING THIS AS A VOLUME
APPROACH TO COLLECTING
INDIVIDUALS TO FILE LAWSUITS IN
THE PLAINTIFF OR DEFENDANT
RATHER WILL BE INCENTIVIZED TO
SETTLE THESE THINGS OUT OF
COURT BECAUSE JUST THE SHEER
COST OF LITIGATION SO I THINK
THIS WILL ACTUALLY IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S FAIR BECAUSE YOU DO
HAVE INDIVIDUALS. WHO DON'T
HAVE THE FINANCIAL WHERE WITH
ALL TO HIGHER INTEREST ON TO
WORK TO BE ABLE TO ADVOCATE ON
THEIR OWN BEHALF THAT THEY MUST
HIRE AN ATTORNEY. THAT THE
ADVANTAGE IN THE LEVERAGED TO
BE WITH THE DEFENDANT WHICH IS
THE CORPORATION. BUT IF WE'RE
GOING TO BE FAIR I THINK THAT
WE SHOULD ALSO ALLOW FOR THOSE
DEFENDANTS WHO HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT THAT WOULD BE
A FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT THAT THE TO
BE ENTITLED TO THEIR ATTORNEYS
FEES. AND I THINK THAT IS A
CHALLENGE NO DOUBT MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA IS
GOING TO STAND UP RIGHT NOW
POSSIBLY EVEN HER ANOTHER. IF
COLLEAGUES BUT I THINK THIS IS
THE DISCUSSION WE DON'T HAVE
THE BRITISH RULE SYSTEM IN THE
US I UNDERSTAND THAT WHICH
WOULD OTHERWISE ENTITLE THE
PREVAILING PARTY TO COLLECT
ATTORNEYS FEES. BUT IF WE THINK
THAT THIS IS NOT INCENTIVIZE
LAWSUITS IN ALSO SETTLEMENTS
WILL BE SORELY MISTAKEN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER GORGEOUS- I
KNOW CENTER LATER YOU'LL TAKE
THAT IN YOUR CLOTHES I'M SURE
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER DAY DIGITAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER
JACKSON. YES I KNOW IT'S HARD
TO SEE BEHIND THE PLEXIGLAS YOU
HAVE NO IDEA HOW HARD IT IS TO
HEAR. THE PLEXIGLASS BUT I DID
HEAR THAT- LAST UP. ARGUMENTUM
WE DID HAVE THIS DISCUSSION. IN
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. THE
UNITED STATES OPERATES ON THE
AMERICAN SYSTEM. AND THAT IS A
SYSTEM WHERE. WHEN YOU HAVE
RELATIVELY UNEQUAL BALANCE IN A
DEBATE IN A DISPUTE. THE
PLAINTIFF IF THEY PREVAIL. IS
ENTITLED TO ATTORNEY'S FEES.
HOWEVER THE COURT ALWAYS HAS
DISCRETION. AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT. I OFTEN SAY
THAT. THE MANTRA THE MEME IS
EVERY LAWSUIT AS A FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUIT AND EVERY LAWYER IS A
GREEDY TRIAL LAWYERS. BUT THAT
ISN'T THE CASE AND THIS IS JUST
A FALSE AND INACCURATE- A
MESSAGING- BECAUSE THE COURTS
ALWAYS HAVE THE AUTHORITY. TO
EITHER REDUCE OR DENY REQUESTS
FOR ATTORNEYS FEES. AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION IF THE
LAWSUIT IS DEEMED FRIVOLOUS BY
THE COURT THEN ATTORNEYS FEES
ACTUALLY CAN BE GIVEN TO THE
DEFENDANT AS THE PREVAILING
PARTY SO I REALLY HOPE. THAT AS
WE PROCEED WE RECOGNIZE. THAT
SO MUCH OF THIS IS JUST FALSE
PROPAGANDA. THE COURT REALLY
HAS THE DISCRETION YOU WILL NOT
SEE FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS BECAUSE
THE PARTY BRINGING THEM IS
SUBJECT TO A ESSENTIALLY
PUNITIVE ACT MEANING THAT THEY
END UP HAVING TO PAY THE COST.
OF THIS IS A SITUATION. WE'RE
WHICH IS TRYING TO BALANCE OUT.
BETWEEN A WORKER WHO IS THE
SUBJECT OF RETALIATION FOR
DOING SO. THAT THEY ARE
LAWFULLY ENTITLED TO DO BY AN
EMPLOYER WHO IS. A TRY TO IN
THAT RIGHT SUPPRESSANT INTO
AGAINST IT AND IT IS THE
WORKERS RIGHT TO BRING IN A- OR
TO RECOGNIZE. I SHOULD SAY UP
WIN A RAW HAS BEEN COMMITTED
AGAINST THEM- UNDEREMPLOYMENT
LOS AND WHEN THE RETALIATED
AGAINST THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
BRING INACTION IN THAT REGARD
THE WHOLE POINT IS TO. IS TO
DISCOURAGE THAT KIND OF MISUSE
OF POWER THAT THE EMPLOYER HAS
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES WE
HAD AN INTERESTING DISCUSSION
AS WE ALWAYS DO WITH THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM. FRESNO IS
OFFICIAL. YES FROM FRESNO BUT
IT IS A VERY DIFFERENT WAY OF
LOOKING AT THINGS AND I WOULD
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT THERE IS A
REASON FOR THE AMERICAN SYSTEM
AND THIS I IT AND THANK
GOODNESS WE DON'T HAVE THE
BRITISH SYSTEM. BECAUSE I CAN'T
IMAGINE AS A LAWYER HAVING TO
PUT ON A- ROBE IN A WHITE WEEK
SO AMONG OTHER REASONS THIS IS
A GOOD BILL AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY. ALSO ASK FOR YOUR
I. PHONE THANK YOU SO MUCH SENT
JACKSON MEMBERS WE BACK TO GET
A SEAT ANY THIS. OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR. FINAL DISCUSS OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. HERE IN C.
NINE CENTER LABELED LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
THINK THAT THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SANTA BARBARA WAS FORMER
ELOQUENT IN HER LEGAL
BACKGROUND DESCRIPTION TO THE
SENATOR FROM FRESNO I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. BUT I
WOULD JUST SAY THIS. 2000%
RETALIATION CLAIMS FROM
IMMIGRANTS HAVE GONE UP 2000%
NOT TO NOT TWENTY NOT TWO
HUNDRED. TWO THOUSAND AND AS
SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTED WORKERS
FOR TWENTY YEARS WE HAD
EMPLOYERS WHO USED TO WORRY
ABOUT REFERRALS LAWSUITS. I
USED TO TELL THEM. DON'T BREAK
THE LAW IT'S JUST THAT EASY
WITHOUT MEMBERS. RESPECTFULLY
OFFER NOVEL MIDDLESEX CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES NO BELL. FORGES NO
BRADFORD HI CABRERA. CHIANG NO
DALLY NO DOT. HI DURAZO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. NO HEARD. HELLO HI I
HUESO. I HER TADO. NO JACKSON.
HI JOE. NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I MONEY
I MORE LOCK NO MORALE. NO
NIELSEN. NO HAN I PORTANTINO.
FIVE ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER.
STERN NUMBER FIVE WHAT KASKY I
WIENER. I WILK NOW SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE OH TWO
SENATOR MITCHELL. ARE YOU
PREPARED. FIND ONE OR. TWO I
APOLOGIZE I WANT TO BE AN
ACTIVE FILE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE WANT TO FIND A ONE OH
THREE. SENATOR HILL. SENATOR
HILL WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT BUT
A ONE OF THREE. YES MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN AND
ACTUATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SENATOR HILL. THANK YOU MADAM
THE PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
AND- EIGHTY NINE NINETY TWO
SIMPLY CLARIFIES THAT MEMBERS
OF LOCAL ELECTED BODIES. MAY
ENGAGE ON SOCIAL MEDIA PROVIDED
THEY DO NOT INTERACT IN ANY WAY
THAT VIOLATES THE RALPH M.
BROWN ACT MORE SPECIFICALLY AB
NINE NINETY TWO ALLOWS MEMBERS
TO USE SOCIAL MEDIA PROVIDED
THAT A MAJORITY OF THE MEMBERS
DO NOT DISCUSS AMONG THEMSELVES
BUSINESS OF A SPECIFIC NATURE
THAT IS WITHIN THE SUBJECT
MATTER JURISDICTION OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY OF THE LOCAL
AGENCY WILL EVOLVING FORMS OF
COMMUNICATION AND PARTICIPATION
IN SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
LOCAL OFFICIALS HAVE INDICATED
THAT IT IS UNCLEAR WHAT IS
ALLOWED WHEN INTERACTING WITH
THE PUBLIC ON SOCIAL MEDIA
SOMETHING NOT CONSIDERED WHEN
THE RALPH M. BROWN ACT WAS
FIRST ENACTED IN NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE. THE NEW MICRODOSING
ASPECT OF SOCIAL MEDIA IS THAT
IT GIVES CITIZENS NEARLY FULL
ACCESS TO THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS PRIOR TO THE ADVENT
OF SOCIAL MEDIA CONSTITUENTS
ONLY ACCESS WAS TO MAKE AN
APPOINTMENT TO SEE THEIR LOCAL
ELECTED HAPPEN TO RUN INTO THEM
OUT AND ABOUT OR ATTEND COUNCIL
MEETINGS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
ENCOURAGE NOR ALLOW LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO DELIBERATE WITHOUT
NOTICE ON SOCIAL MEDIA BUT
INSTEAD PROVIDES STRUCTURE AND
CLARITY HE INTERACTIONS THAT
ARE MOST LIKELY ALREADY
HAPPENING ONLINE TO EXCLUDE
SOCIAL MEDIA PARTICIPATION HARM
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND DOES A
DISSERVICE TO THE PUBLIC WHILE
UNDERMINING TRANSPARENCY
FOLLOWING RECENT AMENDMENTS
THERE IS NOW NO OPPOSITION TO
AB NINE NINETY TWO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL COLLEGE
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER.
MEMBERS AND OR DEBATE
CENTREBOARD. THIS THANK YOU FOR
COULD THROUGH A ON UNITED TO
POST QUESTION JUST FOR CLERK.
ON TO THE OF FLORAL ON THIS
ORDER ON TO TAKE A QUESTION I
TIME HEARING YOU SORRY PLEASE
I'M SORRY. SO I MIXER NINE
STANDS AT THIS. SO OF CREATES A-
TO THE BROWN AT PROHIBITION
GETS CAN. IN ON INTERNET. WE'RE
ON THE SAME RATE WHICH NOT IT
DOESN'T KNOW FOR SHE COULD. IT
JUST ALLOW FOR THE- IN AND SO
MEDIA. EXACTLY WHAT ALLOWED TO
COME. ON SUBJECT MATTER THAT IS
PERTINENT FOR INVOLVED EXACTLY
THAT'S NOT ALLOWED. ALL RIGHT
SO IF YOU HAD JUST BY WAY OF
EXAMPLE LET'S SAY YOU HAVE A
FIVE MEMBER BOARD LIKE A BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. AND LOCAL
ENTITIES LIKE MUNICIPALITIES
AND COUNTIES ARE BOUND BY THE
BROWN ACT. IF SOMEONE PUTS OUT
ON SOCIAL MEDIA. OPPOSITION TO.
DEVELOPMENT ACTS. IN THREE OF
THOSE SUPERVISORS PARTICIPATE
IN THIS. SOCIAL MEDIA LET'S
CALL IT LET'S SAY FACEBOOK
EXCHANGE. ON THIS DEVELOPMENT
PROJECT. HOW WOULD THAT PLAYED
ITSELF OUT HERE THAT'S NOT
WHICH LAW IT'S NOT NO OKAY.
THAT'S NOT THAT'S THIS IS JUST
ALLOWING HE PARTICIPATION
WITHIN THAT SOCIAL MEDIA WITHIN
THAT PLATFORM BUT NOT IN
INTERACTION ON A SUBJECT MATTER
THAT'S PERTINENT OR. INVOLVED
WITHIN THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
OKAY SO THAT WOULD BE TO FOR
TO. IN A DISCUSS OR DIALOGUE
AMONG THEMSELVES ON SOCIAL
MEDIA WHAT ABOUT THE USE OF
INTERMEDIARIES LIKE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. NO I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT WOULD BE ALLOWED TO EITHER
YOU COULD LISTEN TO THE
CONVERSATIONS. BUT YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ALLOWED TO MAKE
THOSE. DETERMINATIONS NOR HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DISCUSS ARGUE.
DIALOGUE WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES
IN THAT ENVIRONMENT FORGIVE ME
FOR LYING- ROUNDING IT ON THIS
POINT FURTHER ONLY BECAUSE
SOCIAL MEDIA SO PREVALENT. AND
SO MANY ELECTED OFFICIALS
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE
BETTER WITHIN THE BROWN ACT-
OBLIGATION. IF THERE'S A
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT. AND
MULTIPLE MEMBERS OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS ARE DRAWN IN BY
TAGGING ON SOCIALMEDIA. SAYING
PLEASE SUPPORT. OUR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ACCESS COMING
THROUGH THE COUNTY AND
SUPERVISOR ONE TWO AND THREE AT
SOME POINT. INVOLVES THEMSELVES
IN THAT CONVERSATION BY
EXPRESSING THEIR OPINION OR HOW
THE VOTE. WHAT HAPPENS IN THAT
SITUATION AT THAT WOULD BE A
BROWN ACT VIOLATION IS. MY
UNDERSTANDING THIS IS THAT'S
NOT WHAT THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
IT ALLOW FOR THEIR TO. IN OF
THE- AND LISTENING BUT NOT
ACTUALLY EXILED PRESSING EXACT
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR RAZA. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ASSIGNED TO THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE ANALYSIS
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT WHICH MAY
NOT BE REALLY SPECIFIC BUT IS A
CORE ISSUE AND THAT IS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE WHICH HAS AN
ISSUE IN OUR POOR AND ARE
WORKING CLASS AREAS IN BOTH
RURAL AND- URBAN AREAS. AND
THEIR ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
MANY AREAS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE
INTERNET ACCESS IS A LUXURY.
AND WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN LEARN WORK
AND CONNECT. REMOTELY
ESPECIALLY GIVEN CALL WITH
NINETEEN SO I JUST WANT TO
RAISE THAT THERE ARE TWO BILLS
THAT SEEK TO BUILD OF THE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE OUR
STATE NEEDS SB ELEVEN THIRTY IN
AB FIVE SEVENTY. I WANT TO
THANK THE CAUGHT MY COLLEAGUES
FOR WORKING ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE WELL I WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL I DO THINK THAT IT'S OF IT
EVERY TIME THIS COMES UP. WE'VE
GOT TO MAKE SURE. THAT
COMMUNITIES AREN'T LEFT BEHIND
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO DRAW
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU MADAM
MAY I PLEASE THE- EFFORT IS
STILL TO CREATE SOME CLEAR. I
DO HAVE A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR IF HE'S WILLING. SO
CENTER HAS REALISTICALLY A
SUPPORT THANK S. C. DOT FANS
THANK YOU. IN THE BILL AND THIS
IN THE NOW THE BILL IT. THAT
NUMBER OF THE BY THE PROHIBITS
OF THE BY. FROM HIS DIRECT TO
COMMUNICATION INTERNET SOCIAL
MEDIA FIVE REGARDING A MATTER
SO I GUESS JUST WANNA BE CLEAR.
FIRST OF ALL I ASSUME LET. LIKE
US NOT UNDER BROWN BY IF YOU'RE
A SPORTS SUPERVISORS CITY
MEMBER SOMEONE. ON YOUR BOARD
THAT YOU SURVIVE OR SIR ON YOUR
CITY COUNCIL YOU SURVIVE. POST
SOMETHING ABOUT A PIECE AN
ORDINANCE OR SOMETHING THAT'S
ON THE AGENDA FOR. YOUR BODY IS
THIS BILL EXPLICITLY SAYING
THAT THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THAT
BODIES. ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
COMMENT ON THAT POST. OUR THAT
POSTING- THAT'S A TWITTER POST
OR FACEBOOK POST OR SOMETHING I
JUST APPRECIATE IF THERE'S A
CLARIFICATION ON THAT WELL IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING OF. THAT THE-
THE PROHIBITION. OF THE BROWN
ACT STILL APPLIES TO THE SOCIAL
MEDIA SO IF THERE ARE THREE
MEMBERS OF A FIVE MEMBER BODY
PARTICIPATING COMMENTING OR
INTERACTING WITH IN THAT THAT
WOULD BE A BALL LIKE VIOLATION
OF THE BROWN ACT AND IT STILL
WOULD BE. ON THIS IT'S MORE TO
BE INVOLVED WHERE YOU CAN
LISTEN PARTICIPATE BE ENGAGED
IN IT IN THAT IN THAT SENSE BUT
NOT ACTUALLY MAKING DIRECT
COMMENTS OR- OPINIONS OR
ARGUMENTS. IN THAT PLATFORM
IT'S MORE OR LESS TO BE
INVOLVED IN LISTENING TO THAT
PLATFORM WOULD BE INVOLVED WITH
IN THE PLATFORM FOR THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE COMMUNITY
AND ALLOWING YOUR CONSTITUENTS
TO USE THAT PARTICULAR
PLATFORM. BUT NOT WHEN THERE
ARE THREE MEMBERS MAKING ANY
DETERMINATION OR IS OUR GOOD
FRIEND FROM FRESNO TALKING
ABOUT A SERIAL MEETING THAT
WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED. AND THEN
THOSE ARE STILL CLEARLY DEFINED
WITHIN THE BROWN ACT AND WOULD
APPLY HERE OKAY SO- I
APPRECIATE THAT I KNOW YOU'RE.
TO FLOOR JOCKEY AND NOT THE%
ACTUAL AUTHOR OF THE BILL AT I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TO AT I
WANT TO FOR. JUST WHAT THEY NOW
SAYS IN TERMS OF. CERTAIN TWICE
AND ENTERED BROWN THIS YOU HAVE
A MAJOR OF PEOPLE. BUT AT LEAST
THEY NOW SEES SOME THAT EVEN A
PROTEST BASED OTHER MEMBERS. OF
THE SAME BODY SHOULD BECOME. ON
IF ANYONE OF BODY POSTING ABOUT
SO SOME PEACE BUSINESS BEFORE
THEIR- SO DINNER TIME ADVOCATE
BY PRE YOUR S. THANK YOU THINK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATORS.
ANY DOES. OR DEBATE. SEEING
HEARING NONE MEADOW SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS I BATES
NO BELL FOR JUST HIGH BRADFORD
HI CABRERA I CHIANG. DALLY DOT
FIVE THE RAZA HI GALGIANI. AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO I
HER TADO HI JACKSON. I JONES HI
LEYVA HI MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL. I MONNING. FIVE
MORLOCK I. MORE LIKE A HIGH
MORALE. NO NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH. I RUBIO HI
SKINNER STERN NUMBER FIVE WHAT
KIND OF SKI FIVE WIENER I WILK.
I SENATOR MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS
WE WILL GO THROUGH THE ROLE
AGAIN AT THE END WHEN WE HAVE
ALL MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR FOR A
GO THROUGH ONE TIME BUT WE
WON'T LET YOU NOT GET TO VOTE
PROMISE OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE OH
FIVE. SENATOR HUESO. METAL
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AND
ACTUALLY INTO BUSINESS SENATOR
HUESO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE THIS AFTERNOON
TO PRESENT A B. THIRTY TWENTY
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA THIS BILL EMPOWERS THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO ITH THE
TOOLS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND THE ENVIRONMENT
BY ENSURING. JUST COMPENSATION
FOR ITS EFFORTS NOW AGAIN ON
MAKE CLEAR THIS BILL ONLY
PERTAINS TO SAN DIEGO AND
WITHIN THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
UNDER EXISTING LAW ONLY PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS MAY FILE LAWSUITS
CHARGING UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES THESE ACTIONS MAY BE
BROUGHT FORWARD BY AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL. A DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FOR A CITY ATTORNEY OF ANY CITY
WITH A POPULATION OF A GREATER
THAN SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND. WHEN A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY BRINGS FORWARD AN
ACTION UNDER THE FAIR COMPANY
UNFAIR COMPETITION ACT THAT
ALSO OFFICE NORMALLY RECEIVES
ALL OF THE CIVIL PENALTIES ARE
REWARDED BY THE COURT. HOWEVER
WHEN THE CITY ATTORNEY BRING
SUCH AN ACTIONS BOTH CIVIL
PENALTIES MUST BE SPLIT. EVEN
WITHIN EVENLY WITHIN THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF THAT
COUNTY WHETHER OR NOT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WAS INVOLVED
AT ALL IN THE LAWSUIT. THIS
DISCREPANCY IS LEFT. THOSE
ELIGIBLE CITY ATTORNEYS WITH
WITH A DIFFICULT CHOICE
BALANCING THE PURSUIT OF LEGAL
RECOURSE AGAINST UNSCRUPULOUS
ACTORS. WITH THE REALITY OF-
HAVING TO HAVE FINITE RESOURCES
AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
COMPENSATE THEMSELVES FOR THE
WORK THAT THEY PERFORM. AB
THIRTY TWENTY REQUIRES
PENALTIES COLLECTED BY THE CITY
ATTORNEY FROM AN ACTION UNDER
THE UNFAIR COMPETITION ACT TO
BE PAID TO THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO ENTIRELY IN THE CASE
WHERE THE CITY ENTIRELY DID ALL
THE WORK. BY ENSURING AN
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF PEP
PENALTIES REPORTED UNDER THE ON
FOR. ACT THIS BILL WILL EMPOWER
THE SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY TO
PROSECUTE AND GUESTS ON FOR
BUSINESSES IN THE INTEREST OF
CONSUMERS AND THE ENVIRONMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND NONE. CENTER
MORE UP. PRESIDENT WE'VE ALL
BEEN MAKING LOTS OF SACRIFICES
WITH ARBIL PACKAGES AND- I'M
JUST CURIOUS HOW DOES THIS
RELATE TO COVE IT DIDN'T WHY
ARE WE DOING SOMETHING. SO
DETAIL PER ONE COUNTY AND NOT
THE OTHER FIFTY SEVEN- WHEN
WE'VE WE'VE GOT YOU KNOW PRETTY
TIGHT BILL LOW DOG I'M JUST
SORT OF CURIOUS ABOUT A
PRESIDENT WHAT. OUR
PRIORITIZING THESE BILLS. WERE
YOU ASKING ME THAT QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY I THINK SO. OKAY.
CINEMARK MOVIES ARE BILLS THAT
ARE ASSEMBLY BILLS AS YOU WELL
KNOW THERE PROPERLY BEFORE US
AND WE'RE NOT SURE HOW OLD THE
ASSEMBLY PRIORITIZE THEIR BILLS.
CASH BETTER FOR THE SPEAKER TO
ANSWER YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT A
LONG WEEKEND HAD JUST KIND OF
WANT TO BE CURIOUS ABOUT HOW.
CERTAIN THINGS ARE BEFORE START.
NO I WOULD GIVE A CALL HE
PROBABLY ANSWER THAN I DO DID.
YES SENATOR BORDERS. WHEN THIS
FIRST CAME TO- JUDICIARY LAST
YEAR OF COURSE IT DIDN'T END UP
PASSING- I THINK THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF CONCERNED COUNTIES
THAT WHEN MUNICIPALITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE GETTING PITTED
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER ALL OF US
WITCHFINDER CELLS WITH CIVIL
WAR IN OUR BACKYARD ASSUMING
YOU HAD THE POPULATION
THRESHOLD- THAT WAS ORIGINALLY
PUT FORTH AND BACK THEN IT WAS.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND NOW IT
BECAME A DISTRICT BILL- BUT I
WOULD ALSO ADD CAUTION THAT WE
START CARVING OUT THESE
COUNTIES. TO KEEP THE PHONE
THIRD OF THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS ARE
DIFFERENT IN THEIR ANNUAL-
NEGOTIATED RATES I THINK THAT
SETS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT FOR
CITY COUNTY RELATIONS I WOULD
JUST CAUTION MY COLLEAGUES WE
COULD BE OPENING A PANDORA'S
BOX HERE WITH THE SEPARATE-
DOLLAR AMOUNTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SAID REPORTER MEMBERS
ANY FOR JUST OR DEBATE. SENATE
JACKSON. YES THANK YOU I FEEL
CAN TO GET UP WHEN THE ISSUE IS.
MATTER IN THE JUDAS COMMITTEE.
THIS WAS A BILL THIS YEAR THAT-
ACTUALLY IT DIDN'T CREATE ANY
KIND OF TURF BATTLES THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN. THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO WE'RE IN
AGREEMENT ON THIS. IT'S
ACTUALLY A VERY INTERESTING
ISSUE ABOUT WHO SHOULD BENEFIT
WHEN SOMEONE BRINGS IN ACTION
AND UP UNTIL NOW AND IN OTHER
COUNTIES. THAT THOSE DOLLARS
ARE SPLIT- SAN DIEGO FELT THAT
IT WAS APPROPRIATE FOR THE
FUNDS TO GO TO THE CITY
ATTORNEY THE COUNTY WAS NOT
ENOUGH OPPOSITION. AND THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF BILLS IN THIS
FLOOR THAT OUR ADDRESS TO LOCAL
SITUATIONS IN THIS CASE. WE HAD
PEOPLE IN AGREEMENT AND THAT
WAS THE BASIS UPON WHICH WE
PASSED THE BILL OUT. OF THE
JUDICIARY AND THE BASIS FOR
WHICH I RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
JACK MEMBER FOR THE- OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING ANSWERED WAS
ALWAYS TO CLOSE JUST MICHAEL
WITH OF JACKSON WITH THE RIVER
PURPOSE FOR CLOSE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I
BATES NO BELL FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD HI CABRERA I CHIANG.
NO DALLY NO DODD. HI DURAZO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. HI HILL
AYE HUESO AYE FOR TADO HI
JACKSON. I JONES NO LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S. MITCHELL
HI MORNING I MORLOCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN. NO HAN I PORTANTINO
I ROTH. I RUBIO I SKINNER STERN.
NUMBER I MY COUNTY I WIENER I
WILK NO. SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS WE ARE ON TO I'D ONE
KNOWS SENATOR TO RUN MA'AM SAID
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE THIRTY THREE BY ACT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND ACTUALLY INTO REFUGEES
CENTER TO RUSSELL. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ALL RIGHTS TO
PRESENT AB THIRTY THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THREE THIS BILL CODIFIES
CALIFORNIA'S LONG STANDING
COMMITMENT TO RESETTLING.
REFUGEES WITHOUT DISCO. AS PART
OF THE US READ. AND PLACEMENT
PROGRAM TELL HAS A LONG HISTORY
OF OFFERING REFUGE HAVING
REACHED RECEIVED NEARLY ARRIVED
REFUGEES SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
THERE ARE MEN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN FORCED TO FLEE THEIR
HOMES TO SEEK SAFETY THE WAR
PERSECUTION FOR RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS OR POLITICAL OPINION.
THESE REFUGEES THEN TURN AROUND
AND CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE
INCLUDING SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN SPENDING POWER AND
THE DIVERSITY WE ARE SO PROUD
OF THIS BILL SIMPLY CODIFIES
INTO LAW IN OUR LAW THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO UPHOLD OUR
COMMITMENT. TO ASSISTING THOSE
SEEKING REFUGE IN OUR COUNTRY
AND STATE. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND IT IS A LATINO
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL I ASK FOR
YOUR ON BOTH. THANK YOU SENATOR
DORADO MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
THAT MEANT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
WELL FORGES. BRADFORD HI
CABRERA I CHIANG I DALLY. DODD
FIVE TORONTO I GALGIANI FIVE
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
HER TADO I JACKSON I JOE. I
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ AYE
MITCHELL. I MONEY FIVE MORLOCK.
MORALE NIELSEN. PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER STERN NUMBER FIVE WHAT
KASKY FIVE WIENER I WILK. I
FORTIS BOARD DECIDE. SENATOR
BORDERS. MA'AM SAID THANK YOU
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE ELEVEN SENATOR
MCGUIRE. FENDER MUSICAL
THERMADOR WOULD YOU TO PRESENT
FOLLOW ONE LET. HAVE FUN FILE
REMOVE TO FOR BY. ONE TWENTY.
SENATOR HILL NOT AT HIS DESK WE
ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. ONE
TWENTY TWO SENATOR MONICA MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN FORTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARK STONE AND ACTUALLY
INTO PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SENATOR MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AB ELEVEN FORTY IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT WOULD HELP
THE CENTRAL FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT AND AFTER US WHAT SO A
FIVE PER THIS. TO CONSOLIDATE
WHILE MAINTAINING THEIR BENEFIT
OBLIGATIONS TO EXISTING
EMPLOYEES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REPORT RECOMMENDED THAT A
MERGER OF THE TWO DISTRICTS
WOULD RESULT IN SAVING FOR
SWEAR TAXPAYERS ARE PRESERVING
THE EXISTING LEVEL OF FIRE
PROTECTION SERVICES. SINCE THAT
TIME BOTH DISTRICTS HAVE WORKED
WITH OUR LOCAL LAUGH GO TO MOVE
THIS CONSOLIDATION FORWARD ONE
ISSUE THAT REMAINS IS THE
ABILITY TO CONTINUE THE
EXISTING BENEFITS FOR BOTH
GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE AN EXEMPTION FOR
THESE TWO AGENCIES TO BE ABLE
TO MERGE. AND HAVE THE
SUCCESSOR AGENCY PROVIDE THE
EMPLOYEES WITH THE BENEFIT
PACKAGES THEY ALREADY RECEIVE
WITHOUT THIS BILL ONE AGENCY
WOULD HAVE TO ASSUME THE
CONTRACTS OF THE OTHER AGENCY
AND BENEFITS FOR THOSE
EMPLOYEES WOULD CHANGE. AB
ELEVEN FORTY HAS SUPPORT OF THE
EMPLOYEES AND CALPERS HAS NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IN SPECIAL RECOGNITION
TODAY FOR THE WORK THESE
FIREFIGHTERS ARE DOING ON THE
FRONT LINES IN THE SANTA CRUZ
MOUNTAINS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR MONNING MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
OUR ON CALL ROLL CALL THERE IS
OBJECTION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. OF PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES I TELL. PORGES
I BRADFORD FIVE CABRERA. I
CHIANG FIVE DALLY. FIVE DODD HI
TORONTO I GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG I HILL I HUESO BY HER
TADO HI JACKSON I JONES. I
LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
I MITCHELL. I MONEY FIVE
MORLOCK MORALE. FIVE NIELSEN
FIVE PAN. FIVE PORTANTINO. FIVE
ROTH HI RUBIO I SKINNER. STERN
AMBERG I WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER. FIVE WILK I SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY SENATOR HILL MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY INTO EMPLOYMENT AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY
SIX CLARIFIES AMBIGUITY IN
CURRENT LAW BY PROVIDING THE
PART TIME ADJUNCT FACULTY AT
NONPROFIT INDEPENDENT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES CAN CONTINUE
TO BE TREATED AS THE EXAM
PROFESSIONALS THAT THEY ARE.
THE BILL SETS A MINIMUM
COMPENSATION FLOOR BASED ON A
FORMULA FOR TOTAL HOURS OF
SERVICE NOT JUST CLASSROOM TIME
TO ACCOUNT FOR TIME SPENT
PREPARING LESSONS GRADING
ASSIGNMENTS IN RESPONDING TO
STUDENTS SPONSORED BY THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND SEIU. THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT ADJUNCT
FACULTY MEMBERS ENJOY
FLEXIBILITY AND INDEPENDENCE
WELL BENEFITING STUDENTS WITH
THEIR PROFESSIONAL EXPERTISE
EXPERIENCE OUR FACTORY AS RIVAL
COLLEGE. THANK YOU CENTER HELL
MEMBERS OF THE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMSIC PLEASE THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS FIVE BATES.
I TELL FORGES I BRADFORD I HAVE
A I CHIANG I VALLEY. I DODD.
FIVE DURAZO WELL I GALGIANI
GOTCHA AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. FIVE HERTZBERG FIVE
HELLO AYE HUESO I HER TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES. I LEYVA FIVE
FIVE MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S AYE
MITCHELL. FIVE ONE NINE FIVE
MORLOCK. FIVE ZERO. I NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO. FIVE
ROTH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER. STERN
I'M I MY COUNTY I WIENER FIVE
WILK I CENTER MUSICAL MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO FIVE ITEM WANT
TO FOUR SEN MON MEN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY BY A
BOERNER HORVATH AND ACTUALLY IT
INTO RESOURCES CENTER MONNING
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
CODIFIES THE SUBSTANCE OF TWO
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS THAT WERE
SIGNED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. BY
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES SETTLING
MULTIPLE LAWSUITS THAT SPANNED
NEARLY A DECADE THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT PERMANENTLY PROTECTS
THE SENATE- FREE STATE BEACH BY
STABBING AVOIDANCE AREAS WHERE
ROAD CONSTRUCTION IS PROHIBITED
PROTECTING THE PARK IN STATUTE
MEANS THAT ENDS YEARS OF
FIGHTING OVER BUILDING OF A
ROAD. ON A LOCATION THAT HAS
BEEN DEEMED ENVIRONMENTALLY AND
LEGALLY IN FEASIBLE AND ALLOWS
LOCAL TRANSPORTATION AGENTS
INCIDENT LEADERS TO PURSUE
OTHER FEASIBLE OPTIONS THE BILL
ENJOYS SUPPORT FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
STATE AND LOCAL BUILDINGS AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES. AS WELL AS
PARK SUPPORTERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR MONNING MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SENATOR BATES. YOU SHOULD BE
GETTING MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
THERE'S A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
COMPONENT TO THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT WHICH I HARDLY
SUPPORT AND THAT'S THE
CONSERVATION EASEMENT FOR OF
THE AREA THAT IS IN SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY THAT IS HAS
EXTREMELY HIGH CONSERVATION
VALUES IN IT BECAUSE SOMETHING
THAT I'VE WORKED ON NOW ANOTHER
AREA AN ORANGE COUNTY WHEN I
WAS A MEMBER OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
FOR ABOUT EIGHT YEARS WE WERE
ABLE TO PRESERVE ABOUT ELEVEN
HUNDRED ACRES. HOWEVER IN THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT THERE'S A
VERY CONTENTION OTHER COMPONENT
REGARDING THE COLLECTION OF
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES OF FOR
A ROAD THAT IS NO GOING. TO OF
DIVERSE THAT A AT NO ARE MOVE
SOUTH OF LOS PARKWAY AND I
THINK YOU HEARD ME. PAUSE
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO THAT ARE ON
ANOTHER THAT'S TO RESOLVE THE
IMPACT FEE ISSUE AND THAT
REMAINS TO BE VERY CONTENT AND
SUBJECT OF LITIGATION SO FOR
TODAY I WILL- ABSTAINED ON THIS
BILL WITH THE HOPES THAT EITHER
THROUGH THE LITIGATION
RESOLUTION OR COMPROMISE THAT
CONTINUES TO BE DISCUSSED
BETWEEN THE TWO PARTIES SUBJECT
TO LITIGATION- THAT WOULD BE
CERTAINLY THE BETTER SOLUTION
THAT I WILL LAY OFF TODAY AND
HOPE THAT IS RESOLVED IF NOT I
WILL HAVE SOME NEW LEGISLATION
TO BEGINNING WITH THE NEW
SESSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER BATES MA'AM FURTHER
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND THAT SORT OF MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MAY PRESS. AND AGAIN
AFTER. ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE ON
THIS **** AGREEMENT. AMONG
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER MONNING THAT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS.
I BASS. BELL FOR JUST. BRADFORD
I HAVE A FIVE CHIANG. DALLY
DODD FIVE TORONTO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO I JACKSON FIVE JONES
NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S. MITCHELL I MONEY
FIVE MORLOCK MORALE. NO NIELSEN.
PAN FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. STERN UMBERG
FIVE FIVE CASKEY I WIENER. I
WILK. CENTER MUSICAL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY FIVE SENATOR WIENER
WHICH I PRESENT ITEM ONE FIVE
BENHAM SAID PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AND
ACTUALLY TO LAND USE. SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU IN A PRESS
ARE ARE RIGHTS TO AB FIFTY ONE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WORKS AB TWO FIFTY ONE WILL
ALLOW HOUSING DEVELOPMENT- I
HAVE. WHAT TO BE THAT ON BASED
PROPERTIES TO ELIMINATE PARKING
SPACES AND WOULD ALLOW
RELIGIOUS USE PARKING SPACES TO
COUNT TOWARDS LOCAL PARKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR HOUSING
RELIGIOUS COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ARE EXPRESSING
INTEREST IN BUILDING HOUSING ON
THEIR EXISTING PROPERTY
INCLUDING ON A CHASE ON
PROPERTY ADJACENT TO THEIR
EMPTY PARKING LOTS IN ORDER TO
EASE CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS. HOWEVER PLANS TO BUILD
NEW HOUSING ON RELIGIOUS
PROPERTIES OFTEN FACED
ROADBLOCKS INCLUDING INCLUDING
LOCAL ZONING REGULATIONS ONE OF
THE MOST COMMON IS THE LOCAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR RELIGIOUS USE
PARKING LIMIT ABILITY TO COUNT
AVAILABLE- PARKING TOWARDS
RESIDENTIAL PARKING
REQUIREMENTS ARE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS INCREASE
CONSTRUCTION COSTS AND CREATE A
FINANCIAL BARRIER FOR
NONPROFITS SUCH AS RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INCREASE THE OVERALL HOUSING
SUPPLY. AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE
WILL FACILITATE THE HOUSING
PRODUCTION THAT OUR STATE
DESPERATELY NEEDS- BY REDUCING
PARKING REQUIREMENTS ON
RELIGIOUS PROPERTIES FOR
QUALIFYING HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
OF THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
TREMENDOUS SUPPORT FROM LOCAL
COMMUNITIES OF FAITH NONPROFIT
AND SO FORTH I RESPECT ASK
FRONT. THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER
MEMBER ANY DISCUSSION AND OR TO
BE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MANSERGH PLAY CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. NO BELL. PORGES BRADFORD
HI CABRERA AYE CHIANG. I DALLY.
I DODD AYE DURAZO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG. I HILL I HUESO I
HER TADO I JACKSON. I JONES I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ AYE
MITCHELL. I MONNING AYE MORLOCK
AYE MORRELL. NIELSEN HI PAM AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH. FIVE RUBIO.
I SKINNER STERN NUMBER HI I MY
COUNTY I WE I WILK I
SENATE-ROOM MEMBERS REMOVE TO
FIVE ITEM TWENTY SIX SENATOR
MITCHELL MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
FIFTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COME
LONGER AND ACTUALLY INTO
PROBATION. SENATOR MITCHELL
THANK YOU MUCH MATTER PRO I
RISE TO PRESENT A NINE FIFTY R.
A. B. THAT IS ONE OF THE
PRIORITY BILLS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KAMLAGER IT WOULD CREATE
A REASONABLE AND EVIDENCE BASED
LIMIT ON PROBATION TERMS
SETTING A MAXIMUM PROBATION
PERIOD OF ONE YEAR FOR
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSES. AND TWO
YEARS FOR SOME FELONY OFFENSES
THE BILL EXEMPTS CRIMES
COMMITTED AGAINST MONETARY
PROPERTY VALUED AT OVER TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND ANY
SPECIFIC CRIMES WITH PROBATION
TERM LENGTH AND IDENTIFIED BY
STATUTE WHICH INCLUDES THE WHY
IS THE MESSAGE BONTA FENCES AND
STRIKE FELONY OFFENSES. MANY
SEX CRIMES AS WELL AS OTHER
TYPES OF CRIMES ARE INELIGIBLE
FOR PROBATION BY STATUTE AND
ARE THEREFORE ALSO EXAM.
PROBATION CAN ONLY BE GRANTED
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CONVICTED OF A CRIME. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY RETAIN JUDICIAL
DISCRETION I RECOGNIZE THE
PROBATION CAN STILL BE REVOKED
BY JUDGE FOR SUBSTANTIVE
VIOLATIONS. IF AN INDIVIDUAL
COMMITS A NEW CRIME ON
PROBATION THEY WILL BE
SENTENCED TO NEW TIME. SUBURBAN
SYSTEMS. WHAT IS THE TO SUPPORT
AND CONNECT THEM TO ESSENTIAL
COMMUNITY SERVICES TO
FACILITATE SUCCESS CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM CURRENTLY DOES THE
OPPOSITE. NEARLY ONE QUARTER OF
CALIFORNIA'S PRISON POPULATION
IS BEHIND BARS FOR VIOLATING
THE TERMS OF THEIR PROBATION OR
PAROLE COSTING THE STATE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY PART
OF THAT EXPENSES TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION TO
INCARCERATE PEOPLE FOR
VICTIMLESS TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS
SUCH AS BREAKING CURFEW ARE
MISSING AN APPOINTMENT WITH THE
SUPERVISION OFFICER. CRIMES
THAT PEOPLE NOT I'M PROBATION
WOULDN'T THINK TWICE ABOUT.
THIS SYSTEM DISPROPORTIONATELY
HURTS PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
PARTICULARLY BLACK PEOPLE WHO
MAKE UP 80% OF THE STATE'S
RURAL POPULATION BUT 23% OF
PEOPLE ON PROBATION. PEOPLE
LIKE RUSSIA BROKE WHO STRUGGLE
TO FOR WORK PAPER AND COURT
FEES FEARING THAT WITHOUT
PROPER. HE MAY NEVER ENTER
SOCIETY FULLY UNFORTUNATELY
DIDN'T GET THAT CHANCE IN JUNE
OF THIS YEAR HE WAS SHOT AND
KILLED BY POLICE OFFICER IN THE
WENDY'S PARKING LOT. OR PEOPLE
LIKE ULISES RIGHT. WHO HAD HIS
PROBATION EXTENDED BECAUSE HE
COULD NOT COMPLETE HIS FINAL
TWELVE HOURS OF COMMUNITY
SERVICE. HELPING TO CLEAN THE
BEACH BECAUSE OF THE COLD AT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT PROBATION SERVICES
SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND
ADDICTION TREATMENTS ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE DURING THE FIRST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF SUPERVISION
THOSE WHO COMMIT A NEW CRIME DO
SO WITHIN THE FIRST TWO YEARS
WHERE THEY CAN BE CHARGED UNDER
THIS BILL. PROVIDING INCREASE
THE PROVISION OF SERVICES
EARLIER REDUCES AN INDIVIDUAL'S
LIKELIHOOD TO RECIDIVISTS.
OPPOSITION TO A B. NINETEEN
FIFTY AGREE WITH THE POLICY IN
FACT THEY SUPPORTED IT IN THE
GOVERNOR JANUARY BUDGET. THEIR
CONCERN IS THAT REDUCE
PROBATION TERMS WILL RESULT IN
REDUCED FUNDING FOR PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS. SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT
WOULD SET UP THE FUNDING
FORMULA FOR WITH FOR PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THESTATE AS A PERFORMANCE BASED
MODEL. LIMITING TERMS SHOULD
NOT AND DOES NOT LIMITED
DEPARTMENTS ABILITY TO SUPPORT
PEOPLE ON PROBATION WITH
PROGRAMMING AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ACCESS AND ACCESS THE
INCENTIVE BASED THE FUNDING AND
SB SIX SEVEN EIGHT. AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE PROGRAMMING NOT
HOW LONG SOMEONE IS ON
PROBATION. AB NINETEEN FIFTY
PROVIDES THE IMPETUS FOR
COUNTIES TO REDESIGN PROBATION
PROGRAMS BASED ON PRESUMING
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES. CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN STATES LIKE
LOUISIANA AND MICHIGAN ARE
ALREADY THINKING PROBATE
RETHINKING PROBATION AND
LOWERING THEIR RECIDIVISM RATE
SUCCESSFULLY. IT'S TIME WE PUT
REFORM APPROBATION SYSTEM FOR
DECADES PROBATION HAS HELPED
EXACERBATE THE VERY REAL AND
MISTRUST THAT DEFINE MANY
COMMUNITIES INTERACTION WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AB NINETEEN
FIFTY WOULD REDUCE RECIDIVISM
BUT PUT PEOPLE ON A SPRINGBOARD
TO SUCCESS AND ENCOURAGE AND
EXPAND EVIDENCE BASED ANTI
RECIDIVISM PROGRAMS. IT WOULD
ENABLE LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
PROVIDE MORE EFFECTIVE SERVICES
AND REDUCE UNNECESSARY CONTACT
WITH THE PUBLIC. MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT WOULD MAKE
COMMUNITIES SAFER I ASKED FOR
AN ADULT. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL MEMBERS DISCUSSION.
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING IN HERE
NONE MA'AM SIR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES NO BELL FORGES.
FOR JUST NOW BRADFORD AYE
CABRERA. CHIANG NO DALLY NO
DODD. DORADO I GALGIANI. GLAZER
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
HILL I WESTERN. HURTADO NO
JACKSON FIVE JONES NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. FIVE MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL I MONEY I MORLOCK NO
MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO HAN. I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO I
SKINNER STERN UMBERG. WHITE
HOUSE SKI HI WIENER. I WILK. NO
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY EIGHT SENATOR PAM. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. AT PASS
ON FILE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE
SENATOR MCGUIRE. NOT AT HIS
DESK WE'RE MOVING TO FOR ITEM
THIRD CENTER HURTS. MAN I'M SO
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND
ACTUALLY INTO ELECTIONS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
CENTER HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A MATTER MORE PRESIDENT
JUNE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE. THE SABBATH
DEPARTMENT PROBE FOR COUNTIES
CHICKENS RISK LIMITING AUDITS
DURING THEIR OFFICIAL
CANVASSING PERIOD OF AN
ELECTION. THIS MEASURE REVISES
THAT PROGRAM TO ELIMINATE SOME
OF THE BARRIERS THAT WERE
DISCOVERED BY THE WORKING
GROUP. WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER HERTZBERG MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING MEN MEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I
BATES I FELT. FORGES I BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO I CHANG AYE DALLY
AYE DODD. I THE RAZA I GALGIANI
I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ FIVE
GROWTH HI HERTZBERG I HILL AYE
HUESO. I HER TADO FIVE JACKSON
I JONES. I LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE
AYE MELINDA'S AYE MITCHELL. I
MONEY FIVE MORLOCK HIGH MORALE.
I NIELSEN I CAN FIVE PORTANTINO.
FIVE ROTH I RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER
STERN NUMBER HI I Y. CASKEY I
WIENER I WILK I SENATOR MOVES
TO CALL MEMBERS TO FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY ONE SENATOR DRAWS SO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AND ACTOR LEADING TO
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION CENTER
TO RUSSELL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEANT. THERE YOU GO YOU'RE GOOD.
OKAY RIGHT I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES TO CONSIDER
HOMELESSNESS AS AN EXTENSION
WAITING CIRCUMSTANCE WHEN
EVALUATING APPEALS THE LOSS OF
FINANCIAL AID JUST AS A
REMINDER. THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
19% OF STUDENTS REPORT BEING
HOMELESS CAL STATE UNIVERSITIES
11% REPORT BEING HOMELESS AND
IN THE UC SYSTEM 5% REPORT
BEING HOMELESS THIS BILL WILL
HELP COLLEGE STUDENTS WERE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS TO
REMAIN ENROLLED. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES AND IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF HOMELESSNESS EDUCATION AND
EDIT EDIT EQUITY ADVOCATES
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL. THANK YOU
CENTER DRAWS SO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR. DEBATE
SENATOR GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'M REALLY GLAD THAT
THIS BODY IS TAKING UP
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL HELP THE
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND- SOMETIMES
SINGLE MOMS ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE GOING TO COLLEGE THAT
ARE STRUGGLING TO EVEN PUT FOOD
ON THEIR TABLE AND- ALSO- THAT
ARE HOMELESS AND I THINK THIS
IS A GOOD SOLUTION AND I WOULD
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE MIGHT CONSIDER
IS THAT WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING
FOR OTHER ALTERNATIVES I'M TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS WHO USED
TO DRIVE FOR UBER AND LIFT AND
MAKE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS. BUT
THE ELIMINATION OF EIGHTY FIVE
HAS LOST A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
REVENUES FOR THEM AND THE
FLEXIBILITY AND FREEDOM IN THE
WORKPLACE. SO I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
WE WILL BE LOOKING FOR MORE
SOLUTIONS IN THE FUTURE. TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE TREMENDOUSLY
LOST AND A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF REVENUE TO HELP THEM NOT BE
IN THE SITUATION THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN TRYING TO PLUG THE
HOLE FOR HOMELESS STUDENTS
CENTER UNIVERSITY SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR GROW MEMBERS FOR
DISCUSS OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING ANSWER ALSO YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS FIVE BATES I FELL.
GORGEOUS OR AYE BRADFORD. I
HAVE A. I THOUGHT. HI TERRAZZA
I GALGIANI I GLAZER. I CONSULT.
I GROWTH. FIVE HERTZBERG AYE
HILL I WAS SO. I HER TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE. FIVE MELENDEZ I
MITCHELL. I MONEY. HI MORLOCK.
HI MURROW. I NIELSEN I PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER STERN NUMBER I LIKE
HOUSEKI I WIENER AYE WILK I
SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS BEFORE
WE MOVE TO OUR NEXT BILLS IS
PRICE SOMETHING WE SHOULD HAVE
TOLD YOU EARLIER IF YOU'RE NOT
SITTING IN YOUR DESK ON THE
FLOOR AND YOU'RE ON ONE OF THE
OUTSIDE GAS WONDERFUL MISTER
PHIL OVER HERE IS THE ONE WHO
CONTROLS YOUR MICROPHONE SO
THERE'S NO NEED FOR YOU TO TRY
AND TURN IT ON AND OFF HE WILL
TURN IT ON FOR YOU OKAY. ALL
RIGHT ROOM TO FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY FOUR SENATOR DORADO. MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TO TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY TO DETENTION
FACILITIES SENATOR DORADO. OKAY
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AB. THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT. HM
ARE PROVIDES ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT FOUR IN FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITIES IN
OUR STATE THIS BILL DOES THIS
BY REQUIRING PRIVATE OPERATORS
TO ADHERE TO THE MINIMUM
STANDARDS THEY ALREADY AGREED
UPON IN THEIR OPERATIONS
CONTRACTS AND PROVIDES FOR A
LEGAL MECHANISM FOR VIOLATIONS
OF THOSE STANDARDS. PRIVATE
CIVIL DETENTION FACILITIES USED
TO HOUSE DETAINEES IN COLOR AND
CALIFORNIA OPERATE UNDER A
SUBPAR INSPECTIONS REGIME. THE
LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY WITH V.
SPEC TO OVERSIGHT AND
CONDITIONS IN THESE FACILITIES.
IT IS THE RESULT OF AN IN AN
ADEQUATE INSPECTION SCHEME
PRIVATE DETENTION OPERATES
CURRENTLY ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
STATE OR FEDERAL OPEN RECORDS
LAWS CIVIL SERVICE REQUIREMENTS
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. AND OTHER
LEGAL CHECKS THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE APPLY QUITE SIMPLY
THE FAILURE OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
BY PROVIDING A CAUSE OF ACTION
FOR VIOLATION OF THESE
FACILITIES WE ARE SENDING A
CLEAR MESSAGE THAT NO ONE IS
ABOVE THE LAW CALIFORNIA WILL
REMAIN WILL ENSURE HUMAN RIGHTS
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND DIGNITY
OF EVERYONE IN. ONE OF THE SIX
INDICATORS GOVERNOR NEWSOM PUT
FORTH FOR LIFTING SHELTER IN
PLACE ICLUDED ENSURING THE
STATE HAD THE ABILITY TO
PREVENT INFECTION IN PEOPLE WHO
ARE AT RISK THIS INDICATOR
INCLUDED FACILITIES AT HIGHER
RISK FOR CONTAMINATION THESE
FACILITIES FIFTH SQUARELY INTO
THAT CRITERIA THE VIOLATIONS OF
STANDARD BY THESE OPERATORS IN
DANGER DETAINEES STAFF AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MICHAEL. THANK YOU
CENTER DRAWS- MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE BENHAM
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES. NO
BELL. FORGES BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I CHIANG. DALLY NO
DODD. I TERRAZZA I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO. I JACKSON. FIVE JONES.
NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. I
MONNING FIVE MORLOCK. NO MORALE
NO NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE. I ROTH.
FIVE RUBIO. I SKINNER STERN
NUMBER FIVE WACO STEVE AYE
WIENER. FIVE WILK. SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FIVE
SENATOR GALGIANI MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY THREE TWELVE BYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY AND
ACTUALLY NEED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CENTER GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AB THIRTY THREE TWELVE PROVIDES
A NARROW EXEMPTION IN
ANNEXATION LAW TO SUPPORT
DEVELOPMENT SUCH AS OFF CAMPUS
STUDENT HUSING AROUND
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
MERCED. THE CAMPUS IS CITED
FOUR MILES FROM THE CITY OF
MERCED AND WHILE COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENTS AROUND THE CAMPUS
WERE ANTICIPATED BY THE STATE
AND UC REGENTS THAT DEVELOPMENT
HAS NOT OCCURRED AS THE CAMPUS
NEARS ITS SIXTEENTH ANNIVERSARY
AND HAS ENROLLED. TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS UC MERCED IS THE
YOUNGEST CAMPUS IN THE UC
SYSTEM AS THE ONLY CAMPUS WHICH
FACES THE CHALLENGE OF EXISTING
AS AN ISLAND OUTSIDE THE
BOUNDARIES OF A CITY OR
DEVELOPED AREA. DESPITE THESE
CHALLENGES THE STATE'S MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT AND
UC MERCED HAS PROVED A MASSIVE
SUCCESS UC MERCED IS THE MOST
ETHNICALLY AND CULTURALLY
DIVERSE CAMPUS IN THE UC SYSTEM
AND HAS ENROLLED MORE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS THAN ANY
OTHER UC CAMPUSES. MORE THAN
70% OF ITS STUDENTS ARE THE
FIRST IN THEIR FAMILY TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND A MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS SPEAK A LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN AND- AT HOME. AB THIRTY
THREE TWELVE ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
THE NEEDS OF A BRAND NEW UC
CAMPUS CITED FOUR MILES OUTSIDE
A PREDOMINATELY RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE SOUTH KING
VALLEY IS NOT A CIRCUMSTANCE
CONSIDERED BY CURRENT LAW. THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW THE CITY OF
MERCED TO ANNEX THE CAMPUS AND
SURROUNDING TERRITORY THREE
ROAD STRIP ANNEXATION
CALIFORNIA LASKO IS NEUTRAL ON
THE LATEST VERSION OF THE BILL
AND IT KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT I
NARROWLY TAILORED EXEMPTION TO
ANNEXATION LAW IS APPROPRIATE
GIVEN THIS VERY UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE. THIS BILL
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTS. AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECT
ACTUALLY ASK FOR VOTE. PLEASE
ENTER GALGIANI ANY DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SENATOR DORADO.
HELLO THE DATA YOU'RE THERE. I
SUPPOSE THE BILL OBVIOUSLY FOR
MANY OF THE REASONS THAT HAVE
BEEN GIVEN A TODAY MY CONCERN
IS. WITH REGARDS TO THE CITY OF
MERCED AND THE AND ITS
OBLIGATION TO IDENTIFY EXISTING
DISADVANTAGED UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES- AND ANALYZE WHERE
THEY HAVE THE ADEQUATE ACCESS
TO BASIC SERVICES LIKE. WATER
AND SEWER- AND SOME AMAZING
THIS BECAUSE I THINK ALTHOUGH
I'M NOT OPPOSED TO IT WE'RE
PROVIDING THAT- FOR UC MERCED
WHICH IS A GOOD THING BUT I
ALSO WNT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE OTHER COMMUNITY OTHER
PARTS OF THE COMMUNITY. WERE OF
THE SAME CONSIDERATION IS GIVEN
THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU
SENATOR DORADO MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE. SEEN
ANSWER GALGIANI MY CLOTHES
THANK YOU I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
TO MY COLLEAGUES BECAUSE OF
CONCERN THAT WAS RAISED THIS
PROPERTY IS OWNED BY A LOCAL
TREST WHICH DEDICATES 1100% OF
ITS REVENUE TO COLLEGE
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR LOCAL HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES ONCE FULLY
FUNDED THE TRUST WILL EXPAND
ITS SCOPE TO EVERY CITY IN
MERCED COUNTY. AND PROVIDE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN SCHOLARSHIPS
ANNUALLY WHILE NO ONE SOLUTION
CAN ADDRESS EVERY ISSUE FACED
BY DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THE GROWTH OF THIS TRUST WILL
DIRECTLY BENEFIT THE KIDS
GROWING UP IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND I WILL ALSO SAY THAT I USED
TO REPRESENT MERCED COUNTY WHEN
I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY FOR SIX
YEARS. AND I KNOW THAT IS THAT
MY COLLEAGUES WHO REPRESENTS
THE AREA NOW IN THE SENATE- SHE
AND MYSELF AND THE AUTHOR OF
THIS ILL WE HAVE ALWAYS WORKED
TO TRY TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
ADEQUATE- CLEAN WATER FOR THE
AREA AND OTHER THINGS AND I WAS
A CONSULTANT TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON UC MERCED WHEN I
WAS A STAFF MEMBER. AND WE
WORKED FOR MANY MANY YEARS TO
FIGHT TO BE ABLE TO TELL THE
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THAT COMMUNITY
THAT WE'RE BUILDING THIS
COLLEGE FOR YOU AND WE WANT YOU
TO ATTEND WE WANT TO LIFT YOU
UP ECONOMICALLY SO THAT YOU CAN
GO TO SCHOOL WHERE YOU LIVE
IT'S WITHIN YOUR REACH AND THEN
HOPEFULLY YOU WILL STAY AND
HELP LIFT THE ENTIRE. CA UP I
ASK FOR YOUR I'VE- THANK YOU
SENATOR GALGIANI. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
OUR ON CALL ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. HIGHS THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTY
NINE SENATOR HILL BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ONE
THIRTY NINE ONE THIRTY NINE
FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTY NINE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD
AND ACTUALLY TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SENATOR HILL THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN
SPECIFIES ADDITIONAL PROCESSES
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE AND DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE MUST INCLUDE AS PART
OF AN INDEPENDENT DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCESS INITIALLY
ESTABLISHED IN OUR TWENTY
SIXTEEN SURPRISE BALANCE
BILLING LEGISLATION. THIS
PROCESS ATTEMPTS TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES ABOUT CLAIMS PAYMENTS
BETWEEN A PROVIDER AND INSURER
THE CHANGES IN THIS BILL ENSURE
THAT THE PROCESS CONSIDERS ONLY
INFORMATION SUBMITTED BY THE
DISPUTING PARTIES. AND THAT
REVIEWERS ARE ASSIGNED TO EACH
CASE BASED ON THE ROLE OF AN
EDUCATION BACKGROUND AND
EXPERIENCE IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR A
CONFIDENTIAL PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR HILL MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES I FELL. PORGES I BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO I CHIANG I DALY I
DODD. I TORONTO FIVE GALGIANI I
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO I
HER TADO. I JACKSON I JONES I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
AYE MITCHELL. HI MY NAME FIVE
MORLOCK AYE MORALE. FIVE
NIELSEN. FIVE TEN FIVE
PORTANTINO HI RALPH. I RUBIO HI
SKINNER. STERN NUMBER NINE FIVE
Y. CASKEY I WIENER I WILK. HI
SENATOR MOVES THE CULT MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SENATOR ALAN. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND ACTUALLY THE PARKING
PENALTIES MISTER ALAN THANK YOU
SO MUCH MEMBERS THIS BILL MAKES
VARIOUS ELIGIBILITY AND
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES TO THE
PAYMENT PLAN PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY LOCAL AGENCIES
RELATED TO PARKING CITATIONS. I
IT IS RECEIVE NO NOVO IN ANY OF
ITS COMMITTEES ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECT US FOR ABOUT. THANK YOU
CENTER ALLEN MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING THE ON CALL ROLL CALL
UNANIMOUS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM OF ONE
FORTY ONE SENATOR CABALLERO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMóN AN ACT
RELATING TO THE CALIFORNIA CUT
FLOWER COMMISSION CENTER
CABALLERO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE OH FIVE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMóN. WHICH CODIFIES A CUT
FLOWER COMMISSIONS. WHICH
CODIFIES THE CUT FLOWER
COMMISSION'S DECISION TO
REACHED TO REDUCE BOARD
MEMBERSHIP FROM THIRTEEN TO
NINE MEMBERS ELIMINATE TERM
LIMITS AND ALSO AUTHORIZES THE
SECRETARY OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO RECONVENE THE
COMMISSION FOR THE BOARD BOARD
VOTE TO DISSOLVE ITSELF IN THE
FUTURE. THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THE SENATE
CABALLERO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEM MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
OUR UNANIMOUS ON CALL ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM OF ONE FORTY THREE.
SENATOR PAN. BUT I DON'T ONE
FOUR YES OKAY AND SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMAN
WOULD IT AND ACTUALLY DOING TO
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT CENTERS- PLEASED TO
PRESENT AT TWENTY SIX FORTY
FOUR ON BEHALF OF- SOME MEMBER
WOULD WHICH TAKEN SEVERAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES THE BILL
REQUIRES DURING A DECLARED
EMERGENCY SUCH AS THE CURRENT
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY TO
REPORT DISEASE RELATED
INFORMATION TO THAT THE PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH INCLUDING EACH
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE RELATED
DEATH OR SUSPECTED DEATH WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS. AND IN TURN
REQUIRES THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO MAKE THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF THESE STATS
AVAILABLE ON ITS WEBSITE ON A
WEEKLY BASIS REQUIRES NURSING
HOME FACILITIES TO HAVE A
DEDICATED FULL TIME INFECTION
PREVENTION IS. BETTER THAN A
PART TIME STAFF PERSON REQUIRES
THE PERSON TO BE A NURSE
REQUIRES ALL HEALTHCARE STAFF
RECEIVE INFECTION PREVENTION
TRAINING ON AN ANNUAL BASIS THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES NURSING
HOMES TO INFORM RESIDENTS TO
REPRESENTATIVES IN FAMILIES.
ABOUT CASES OF COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE AS INSTRUCTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH.
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD OF COVA
DEBTS IN CALIFORNIA
ATTRIBUTABLE TO NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS AND STAFF AND WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT THESE FACILITIES
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN
TO PREVENT INFECTIONS. NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS ARE SOME MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS AND
THEY DESERVE TO BE PROTECTED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER PAM
MEMBERS ANY. DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
OUR UNANIMOUS ON CALL ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVING TO A FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY FOUR ALSO
SENATOR PAM AND SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT CENTER PAM THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS I'M
ALSO PLEASED TO PERCENT AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN BY SOME
MEMBER OF DONALD WHICH
CLARIFIES THAT A PUBLIC AGENCY
MAY NOT AMEND ITS CONTRACT WITH
CALPERS. EXCLUDE GROUPS OF
EMPLOYEES THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
INCLUDED UNDER THAT CONTRACT.
CIVIL SERVICE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA CONTRIBUTE A PORTION
OF THEIR EARNINGS TO THE
CALPERS PENSION TRUSTING THAT
THEIR INVESTMENT PROVIDE A
SECURE RETIREMENT. FORTUNATELY
SOME LOCAL AGENCY OF THE SITE
TO GAMBLE ON A RISKY MODEL THAT
THE PRICE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES OF A
SECURE RETIREMENT BY AMENDING
THE CONTRACT EXCLUDE CERTAIN
GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES. FROM
CALPERS BENEFITS. LIMITING
ACCESS TO CALPERS BENEFITS
ROB'S CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY
WORKERS OF THEIR PENSION
BENEFITS AND FINANCIAL SECURITY
THEY DESERVE. AND COULD
DESTABILIZE RETIREMENT FUND FOR
ALL EMPLOYEES. AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN IS A NARROWLY
TAILORED BILL TO ENSURE PUBLIC
AGENCIES USE THE CALPERS
AMENDMENT PROCESS AS INTENDED.
NOT TO CUT OUT PARTICULAR
GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES FROM THEIR
SECURE RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER PAN
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-CALLING
SAID DEFINED BENEFIT PENSION
PLANS ARE READY LOBSTER TRAPS
FOR. THE PUBLIC SECTOR ONCE YOU
WALK IN YOU JUST CAN'T GET OUT
AND YOU TRY LEAVE CALPERS. THEY
FORCED PLAN SPONSORS TO TRUE UP
IMMEDIATELY. AND THIS IS
EXTREMELY DISINGENUOUS BY. PLAN
ADMINISTRATOR BECAUSE THEY KEPT
THEIR INVESTMENT RETURN
ASSUMPTIONS ARTIFICIALLY HIGH
TO KEEP CONTRIBUTIONS LOW.
SERVICE SORT OF A ACTUARIAL
MALPRACTICE FOR RETIREMENT
SYSTEM PROVIDER SO CITY DECIDED
TO MAKE A FISCALLY PRUDENT MOVE
BY DROPPING. A AN EXPENSIVE
FIRE THIRTY AND RESTARTING
THEIR OWN INTERNAL FIRE
DEPARTMENT. THE TWIST THEY
PROVIDED A DEFINED CONTRIBUTION
PLAN WHICH IS A MORE
APPROPRIATE STRATEGY IN
PURSUING A SHARED RISK APPROACH
TO RETIREMENT PLANS- THIS IS
THE FUTURE IS NOT THE ONLY
MUNICIPALITY OR ENTITY THAT HAS
A DEFINED CONTRIBUTION PLAN FOR
ITS FIRE DEPARTMENT. AB TWO
NINE SIX SEVEN WANTS TO
FORECLOSE ON THIS PRUDENT AND
FAIR FISCAL STRATEGY AND THIS
WOULD BE A TRAGIC MOVE
ESPECIALLY WHEN CITIES TRY TO
RECOVER FROM THE COBIT NINETEEN
LOCKDOWN. SACRAMENTO SHOULD NOT
REMOVE LEGITIMATE AND
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE
ALTERNATIVES IT'S WRONG. IT'S
BULLYING IT'S REMOVING A CLEVER
FROM THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
THAT SHOWS THAT THE LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATURE IS TONE DEAF TO THE
FINANCIAL STRESSES AROUND THE
STATE WE'RE SEEING CITIES
REDUCE THEIR FIRE DEPARTMENTS
BY 25% ALREADY JUST BECAUSE OF
BUDGET CONSTRAINTS. IT ALSO
SHOWS WHO'S RUNNING THE SHOW
AROUND HERE IT IT JUST DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO HAVE UNION
PRESSURE DEMAND HOW ARE DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION PLAN SHOULD WORK
WHEN THE PENSION MELTDOWN
FINALLY ARRIVES. MANY WILL LOOK
AT THIS BILL SHOULD PASS IS ONE
OF THE NAILS IN THE COFFIN.
CONSEQUENTLY MADAM PRESIDENT I
URGE A NO VOTE ON S. B. TWO
NINE SIX SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER MORLOCK MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THE ANSWER
PAN YOU MAY CLOSE. I WOULD JUST
SAY THE FIRST OF ALL THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT LED TO THIS
BILL WHICH BY THE WAY THIS BILL
I WOULD NOT ACTUALLY AFFECT-
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE CITY
PALENCIA A RELEASE CLOSING A
LOOPHOLE BECAUSE BASICALLY WE
TELL LOCALITIES YEAH ARE YOU IN
CALPERS OR YOU'RE NOT AND
THAT'S PART OF MAINTAIN
STABILITY OF THE RETIREMENT
SYSTEM AND ALSO ENSURING THAT.
WE TREAT ALL EMPLOYEES IN A
LOCALITY EQUITABLY JUST HAPPENS
THAT THERE IS A UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT GAVE THE
CITY- PERHAPS AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THERE- TO
BASICALLY TREAT EXCEPT A GROUP
OF EMPLOYEES AND FOURTEEN THE
FIREFIGHTERS THE ONES WHO ARE
YOU KNOW PEOPLE OUT THERE AND
FIGHTING. FIRES FROM BEING
GETTING THE BENEFITS THAT THE
OTHER EMPLOYEES HALF AND SO I
THINK THAT IN THE POINT OF
FAIRNESS- I WOULD ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER PAM MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. I BATES.
BELL GORGEOUS. BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO. I CHIANG. DALLY DODD
FIVE TERRAZZO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER NO GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG I HILL I WITH A-
HURTADO. I JACKSON I JONES.
LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S. MITCHELL. I MONNING
I MORLOCK NO MERLE. NO NIELSEN
NO HAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO. SKINNER STERN NUMBER I
BY CASTING AYE WIENER. I WILK I
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM OR ONE
FORTY SIX SENATOR HER TADO.
PATHAN FILE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY EIGHT SENATOR DORADO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO AND
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT AND
DECLARING THEIR TO SEE THEIR OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
CENTER DRAWS SO. DON'T DON'T
TOUCH IT. OKAY. THIRTY FOUR
CAMP THAT OKAY YOU'RE IN THE
ARE A LIKE. THANK YOU MADAM. I
AM PROUD TO BE. AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE WHICH PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED CLARITY TO THE SECURITY
INDUSTRY AND ENSURE WE CAN
BETTER PROTECT THE WORKERS OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY BY PROVIDING
GUIDANCE TO EMPLOYERS SECURITY
OFFICERS ARE OFTEN THE FIRST TO
RESPOND TO AN EMERGENCY ON
PREMISE AND THEN CALL FOR
ASSISTANCE FROM POLICE OR FIRE
OR AMBULANCE WHEN NECESSARY.
THEY ARE AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT
OF OUR PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE
NATURE OF THE WORK OFTEN
REQUIRES THAT THEIR PRESENT AT
ALL. AB FIFTEEN TWELVE WILL
REQUIRE SECURITY OFFICERS UNDER
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS TO REMAIN ON PREMISE
AND MONITOR RADIOS DURING REST
PERIODS AND IT WOULD PERMIT THE
SECURITY OFFICER TO RESUME
THEIR REST PERIOD AS SOON AS IT
IS PRACTICAL SHOULD THAT PERIOD
BE INTERRUPTED. ADDITIONALLY IF
ON ANY WORK THEY A SECURITY
OFFICER IS NOT PERMITTED TO
TAKE AN UNINTERRUPTED REST
BREAK OF AT LEAST TEN MINUTES
FOR EVERY FOUR HOURS WORKED
THEN THE SECURITY OFFICER SHALL
BE AID ONE ADDITIONAL HOUR PAY
AT THE REGULAR RATE. THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE CLARIFICATION FOR
THE EMPLOYER ON A PROCESS
SHOULD THEY NEED TO INTERRUPT
THE SECURITY GUARDS REST BREAKS
WE HAVE RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IDOL
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
DORADO MEMBERS ANY. DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MEMBERS THERE ANY
OF. CENTER GROVE. I WAS JUST
SAYING GO GO GO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I APPLIED AGAIN
THIS AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- YOU KNOW PAPA LAWS
RESTRICTED LAWS NUMEROUS CREED
RACE RECOVERY PERIODS FOR EVERY
EMPLOYER IN THE STATE IS
DEVASTATING BECAUSE THERE ARE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF-
BUSINESSES SUCH AS A- COMPANION
CARE WHEN YOU TAKE CARE OF A
DISABLED- JUST AND THE SECURITY
GUARD. ISSUE THERE'S A LOT OF
BUSINESSES AND OF THEM WHO IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO STOP
IMMEDIATELY WITHIN THAT TIME
FRAME TO TAKE THEIR BREAK MEAL
AND RESPIRATOR RESTORING EVERY
PERIOD. AND DOESN'T PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY IN OUR NORMAL-
LABOR CODE TO HAVE ANY
FLEXIBILITY WHATSOEVER SO LIKE
A SINGLE MOM THAT WANTED TO IN
DEBT YOU KNOW THREE O'CLOCK IN
THE AFTERNOON AND TAKE FOR OUR
LUNCH BREAK AT THE END OF THE
DAY THERE'S JUST ZERO
FLEXIBILITY. AND SO THIS
ACTUALLY- I REALIZE YOU HAVE TO
BE UNDER COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT BUT THIS ACTUALLY
DOES PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY FOR AT
LEAST SECURITY GUARDS I THINK
WE SHOULD TAKE THIS MOMENT EVEN
TO REALIZE THAT OUR LABOR CODE
IN THE STATE IS SO OVERBURDENED
SEND AN EMPLOYEE SHOULD HAVE
MORE OF A CHOICE AND IT
SHOULDN'T BE CATERED TO JUST
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNITS IT
SHOULD BE. ACROSS THE BOARD TO
CREATE FAIRNESS FOR ALL
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THIS IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND- SO
I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR GROPING ANY FOR
JUST. AND OR TO BE. THING
HEARING THEM DRAW A WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR JUST THAT THE- I'M SURE
THAT PART OF THE REASON THIS IS
FOR COLLECTED THOSE EMPLOYEES
UNDER COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE A VOICE IN THE OUTCOME.
AND THEN THE DECISION BEEN MADE
THANK YOU NICE GROUP BIBLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THE UNANIMOUS ON CALL ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY NINE SENATOR NIELSEN.
PASS OKAY VERY GOOD MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT. ONE MOMENT.
FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY EIGHT THE SENATOR
DIED. ARE YOU PREPARED.
FOR ONE
FIFTY EIGHT FIVE ONE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY EIGHT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW AND
ACTUALLY NEED TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES. GOOD. ROBERT SENATOR
DODD I'M SORRY MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE. MATAMATA CHAIRMAN
SENATORS S. B. TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY NINE WILL HELP MARIPOSA
NAPA. NAPA'S LOCAL ECONOMIES
MAKING AVAILABLE FIVE
ADDITIONAL LIQUOR LICENSE FROM
PUBLIC EATING ESTABLISHMENTS
BOTH THEIR POSE IN NAPA RURAL
COUNTIES WHOSE BUDGET ARE
MOSTLY FUNDED BY TOURISM
DOLLARS. BECAUSE OF THIS
THERE'S BEEN CONTINUED INTEREST
OF THE LOCAL LEVEL IN THESE
COUNTIES TO DRAW AND HOSTS A
LARGE NUMBER OF GROUPS OF
VISITORS UNFORTUNATELY CURRENT
FORM THE USED BY THE ABC IS
TIED TO THE POPULATION OF THESE
COUNTIES WHICH ARE VERY LOW.
THE NUMBER OF LICENSES THAT
REFLECT THE BIG NUMBERS OF
VISITORS EACH YEAR IT PREVENTS
THE ATTRACTION OF CONFERENCE
TYPE HOTEL FACILITIES WHO RELY
ON THE GENERAL A. B. C.
LICENSE. WHILE THIS INFLUX
CONSTRAIN LOCAL SERVICES IT
ALSO CREATES THE CHAIR FOR
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY WHICH IS
IMPORTANT AT THIS TIME. AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE WILL
HELP THEIR OPPOSE A NAP ATTRACT
EVEN MORE VISITORS FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD AS OUR ECONOMY
RECOVERS FROM COVERT NINETEEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVALS.
THANK YOU CENTER DODD MEMBERS.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING IN HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY. TO USING OUR
UNANIMOUS ON CALL ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BROUGH TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI. NOT AT HIS
DESK FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SEVEN
SENATOR JONES. SENATOR JONES
DID YOU WANT PERCENT FALLON ONE
SIXTY SEVEN I KNOW PASS PLEASE
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY EIGHT SENATOR RUBIO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN IN
ACTUALLY DOING TO MENTAL HEALTH
CENTER RUBIO THANK YOU
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIXTY FIVE THIS BILL WAS
REMOVED FROM CONSENT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ADDING TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS. AB FOUR SIXTY FIVE
REQUIRES THAT MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS RESPONDING TO
EMERGENCY CALLS RELATED TO A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS EITHER IN
COLLABORATION OR IN PLACE OF
LINE FOR. PERSONNEL BE
SUPERVISED BY LICENSED MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL THIS BILL
NOT ONLY PROTECTS THE COMMUNITY
AND PROVIDE QUALITY CARE IT
ALSO FREES UP OFFICERS TO FOCUS
ON ISSUES FOR WHICH THEY ARE
TRAINED. THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE PASSED THIS
BILL ON A UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
VOTE IT HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
EYEBALLS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEM BEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE BATES I
FELT BORJAS. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO. I CHIANG I DALY FIVE
DODD. FIVE DURAZO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. I HERTZBERG I HILL I
WAS SO. HI HER TADO. I JACKSON
I JONES I LEYVA I REQUIRE I
MELENDEZ AYE MITCHELL. I
MONNING AYE MORLOCK AYE MORALE.
HI NIELSEN I PAN I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH FIVE RUBIO FIVE SKINNER
STERN NUMBER FIVE CASSIE WIENER
AYE WILK. HI SENATOR MOVE THE
CALL MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
NINE SENATOR NUMBER MEMBERS OF
FOUR FIFTEEN WILL BE LIFTING
THE CALL ON VOTES FOR FIFTEEN
WILL BE LIFTING THE CALL ON
VOTE. SENATOR MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY IN TWO ELECTIONS
SYNDROME BURKE. BOB THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX AND MAY HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA TWELVE SEVENTY SIX IS A
FOLLOW BUILDING AB EIGHT FORTY
NINE THE FAIR MAPS ACT WHAT IT
DOES IS IT ALIGNS- THE LOCAL
DISTRICT ELECTIONS. WITH A
REDISTRICTING IN THE DELAYED
CENSUS US TECHNICAL BILL LAST
RIVAL. THANK YOU SIR I'M BURKE
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. NO BELL
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD I HAVE A I
CHIANG. DALLY NO DODD. I
THEY'RE AWESOME I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I WROTE. NO
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO. I JACKSON I JOE NO
LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ.
MITCHELL I MONNING I MORLOCK.
NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN. CAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER. STERN NUMBER I WHO I
CASTING. WIENER. I WILK NOW
CENTER MUSICAL MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
SENATOR MONNING MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC WORKS CENTER
MONEY THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
ONE DEFINES WHEN A PUBLIC
SUBSIDY IS TO MINIMUS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF DETERMINING IF THE
PREVAILING WAGE APPLIES TO
PRIVATE PROJECTS USING PUBLIC
FUNDS. UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
TERM DE MINIMUS IS NOT DEFINED
IN STATUTE SO THERE'S NO
GUIDANCE FOR INDUSTRY OR
REGULATORS AS TO THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF PUBLIC
SUBSIDY THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED DE MINIMUS AND THIS
IS LEAD TO LITIGATION. THIS
BILL PROVIDES THAT A PUBLIC
SUBSIDY ON A PRIVATE PROJECT IS
DE MINIMUS SO LONG AS IT IS
LESS THAN SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN LESS THAN 2% OF THE
TOTAL PROJECT COST. TO ADDRESS
OPPOSITION CONCERNS THE AUTHOR
AMENDED THE BILL TO INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF PUBLIC SUBSIDY
THAT WILL TRIGGER PREVAILING
WAGE FROM FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS UNDER CURRENT LAW IN
NINETEEN UNDER THIS BILL NO
DEVELOPER IS REQUIRED TO TAKE A
PUBLIC SUBSIDY OVER THE DE
MINIMUS AMOUNT IF THEY DO NOT
WANT TO PAY THE PREVAILING
WAGE. THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS PUT GREAT
FINANCIAL STRAIN ON OUR WORK
FORCE MANY WORKERS HAVE BEEN
LAID OFF HAD THEIR HOURS
REDUCED ROOF TAKEN UNPAID LEAVE
TO CARE FOR THEIR FAMILY IT IS
MORE CRITICAL THAN EVER BEFORE
THAT OUR WORKERS IN THE TRADES
EARN DECENT WAGES AND RECEIVE
QUALITY TRAINING. ON THESE-PROJECTS MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER MONNING MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL BUSINESSES ARE
SHATTERING- AROUND OUR STATE.
AND SOME- ARE NOT EVEN GONNA BE
ABLE TO RE OPEN. WE NEED A
VIBRANT ECONOMY TO BE ABLE TO
GET US OUT OF THE SITUATION
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES IN
BECAUSE OF CODE AND NOT HAVING
BUSINESS BEEN OPERATIONAL.
SINCE BASICALLY MARCH. THIS
BILL PLACES ADDITIONAL BURDENS
AND COST ON- BUSINESSES
STRUGGLING TO STAY OPEN. AND WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE HOUSING
CRISIS IF PRIVATE BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE- WANTS TO BUILD
HOUSING FOR THE HOMELESS WHICH
WE NEED TO ADDRESS BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA HAS 50% OF THE
NATION'S AND SHELTER. AND ARE
HOMELESS POPULATIONS CAN
DRASTICALLY INCREASING. WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BUILD HOUSING
FOR HOMELESS AT A VERY- COST
EFFECTIVE WAY AND I'M NOT
SAYING THE LOWEST BIDDER I'M
SAYING. A GOOD QUALIFIED
CONTRACTOR THEY CAN BUILD
HOUSING FOR HOMELESS THEY CAN
MAKE SURE THAT- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE ADEQUATE HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS POPULATION THERE
SHOULDN'T BE A MANDATE ON IT
FOR A PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS
OR PREVAILING WAGE. SO THAT
HOUSING CAN BE HILL BILL
BECAUSE NEED TO HAVE MORE BILLS
NOT LIST HOUSING BILLS. THE
CURRENT LAW DOES A GOOD JOB OF
BALANCING COMPETING INTEREST IN
USING CONSIDERATION- FOR-
CONSIDERATION OF PROPORTIONS.
M. AND R. EIGHTY TO TWENTY TO
THIRTY ONE PROJECTS ACCEPTING
SUBSIDIES IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR
FORM WILL NOT BE ALLOWED- IT
WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO GET
AWAY FROM THIS- THIS PREVAILING
WAGE REQUIREMENT. SO IF YOU
HAVE A CHURCH FOR INSTANCE THAT
WE JUST PASSED A BILL. AND THEY
WANT TO BUILD HOUSING ON THEIR
PROPERTY IN ORDER TO HOUSE THE
HOMELESS AND THEN OFFER
WRAPAROUND SERVICES BECAUSE THE
FAITH COMMUNITY WILL GENERALLY
DO THAT. SO THAT WE CAN GET
PEOPLE NOT JUST IN HOUSING TO
GET THEM WELL ON THEIR WAY TO A
SUCCESSFUL LIFE- THIS WILL
AFFECT THE CHURCH FACILITIES
THAT ON A BILL THAT WE JUST
PASSED TO ALLOW CHURCHES TO BE
ABLE TO HOUSEHOLD HOMELESS.
POPULATIONS OR BUILD HOUSING
FOR HOMELESS. I JUST THINK
AGAIN AS WE LOOK AT THE CO
PANNED. WE DON'T KNOW RESTRICT
BUSINESS OR COST TO HAVE A-
COST BURDENS. WE JUST NEED TO
BUILD UP AGAIN THIS BILL I KNOW
IT'S NOT JUST FOR BUILDING
HOUSING BUT I'M JUST FOCUSING
ON THAT BECAUSE THE LAST FEW
BILLS THAT WE JUST PASSED. I
JUST THINK THAT WE NOT NEED TO
RESTRICT BUSINESS FROM BEING
ABLE TO. GARNER SUBSIDIES TO DO
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO MAKE
SURE THAT- WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO AGAIN HOUSE HOMELESS. AND I
CAN DO IT IN A PROPER WAY SO
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NUMBER. THANK YOU SENATOR
GROSSING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SENATOR MONNING WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. SHOULD
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE THAT I JUST WANT TO
BE CLEAR. THIS BILL DOES NOT
CREATE PREVAILING WAGE THAT IS
STATE LAW IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL PROVIDES
CLARIFICATION OF WHAT
CONSTITUTES A DE MINIMUS PUBLIC
CONTRIBUTION. IN IN
NEGOTIATIONS THAT LEVEL WAS
RAISED TO PROTECT LOWER COSTS
FROM BEING BOUND BY PREVAILING
WAGE SO AGAIN. THIS BILL
MEMBERS DOES NOT CREATE
PREVAILING WAGE THAT EXISTS
WITH PUBLIC SUBSIDIES IT WILL
ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY. BY KEEPING
PARTIES OUT OF EXPENSIVE AND
TIME CONSUMING LITIGATION BY
HAVING A DEFINED. THRESHOLD
THAT TRIGGERS THAT PREVAILING
WAGE. THE MINIMUS. LEVEL SO FOR
THOSE REASONS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR MONNING
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS
AYE BATES NO BELL I BORDERS NO
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I CHIANG
NO DALLY NO DODD. DURAZO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI HELLO I
WAS SO. HI HER TADO. I JACKSON
I JONES NO LEYVA AYE AYE
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ NOTE
MITCHELL. I MONNING AYE MORLOCK
NOPE MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO HAN.
I PORTANTINO HI ROTH. I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER STERN NUMBER FIVE
WHITE HOUSE SKI. WIENER FIVE
WILK NOW SENATOR MUSICAL
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
SIX AFTER WHICH TIME WE WILL
BEGIN LIFTING CALLS ON BILLS SO
FOR THOSE CENTERS WERE OFF THE
FLOOR COME ON DOWN SO THAT YOU
CAN VOTE ON MEASURES. FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY SIX MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
OH ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
AN ACT RELATING TO JUVENILES
CENTERVILLE. GOOD AFTERNOON
COLLEAGUES TO REPRESENT THIS
BILL AB EIGHT NINE A ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE GIPSON.
THIS BILL WILL ELIMINATE THE
PRACTICE OF VOLUNTARY PROBATION
WHICH YOU ARE PLACED UNDER
PROBATION SUPERVISION FOR
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES EVEN WHEN
THEY HAVE NOT COMMITTED A CRIME.
UNDER VOLUNTARY PROBATION TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF USERS ACROSS
THE STATE ARE SUBJECTIVE
CONDITIONS THAT ALLOW FOR
RANDOM SEARCHES CURFEWS
SURPRISE HOME VISITS DRUG TESTS
AND INTERPRET INTERROGATIONS.
THE CURRENT PRACTICE NAY REALLY
IMPACTS THE DISPROPORTION OF F.
AMERICAN A LATINA EXCUSE. AB
NINE OH ONE TAKES A MORE
RESTORATIVE APPROACH INSURERS
USE ARE PROVIDED SAFEGUARDS
WHEN RECEIVING SERVICES AND
ATTEMPTS TO AVOID THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM ALTOGETHER. THE
BILL RESULT IN MEANINGFUL IN
INTERVENTIONS THAT COME FROM
THE COLLABORATION OF
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE OFFERS WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS CROSSES%
AMENDMENTS ON THE FLOOR WHICH
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BELL MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEN BAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
WELL FIVE LARGEST. BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I CHIANG. DALLY NO
DODD I TERRORIZER. I GALGIANI I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL I HUESO. I HER
TADO. JACKSON I JONES. NO LEYVA
I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL. I MONNING. MORLOCK
MURROW NO NIELSEN. NO PAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. FIVE STERN. NUMBER I
LIKE HOUSEKI. WIENER AYE WILK.
SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS GIVE US
JUST A MOMENT AS WE GET OUR ON
CALL WAS PREPARED AND THEN WILL
START VOTING ON THOSE MEASURES.
NEVER MIND WE ARE WAITING FOR
TO MEMBERS TO COME TO THE FLOOR
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE
ITEM OF ONE. SEVENTY THREE. ONE
MOMENT ONE SEVENTY THREE ARE A
LOT OF VERY GOOD MAN I'M SO.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AN ACTOR RELATING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT CENTER
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND SENATORS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE ONE EIGHT. FIVE EIGHTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IAN CALDERON.
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT WILL ALLOW
THE CITY OF NORWALK TO HAVE
EXCLUSIVE RIGHTS UNTIL THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO PURCHASE
THE BACON SOUTHERN YOUTH
CORRECTIONAL RECEPTION CENTER
AND CLINIC. LOCATED RIGHT IN
THE HEART OF NORWALK AT FAIR
MARKET VALUE IF IT IS
DETERMINED TO BE SURPLUS FOR
STATE PROPERTY BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
THE FACILITY SITS VACANT ON
THIRTY TWO ACRES AND WAS
FORMALLY UTILIZED AS A PLACE
FOR JUVENILE OFFENDERS. THE
CITY OF NORWALK PLANS TO
TRANSFORM THE SITE WITH A MIXED
USE DEVELOPMENT WITH CURRENT
PLANS CALLING FOR NINE HUNDRED
AND NINETY FIVE. RUCTIONS NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE HOUSING
UNITS FOUR HUNDRED. WHICH WILL
BE DEEMED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND FIFTY SIX THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET OF COMMERCIAL SPACE. SINCE
THE FACILITY IS LOCATED LESS
THAN TWELVE HUNDRED FEET FROM A
FREQUENTLY USE TRANSIT STATION
A TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT.
CAN HELP ALLEVIATE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION AND IMPROVE AIR
QUALITY WITH THE RESIDENTS MORE
INCLINED TO BE USING THE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. ASSEMBLY
MAJORITY LEADER WHOSE DISTRICT
OVERLAPS MY THIRTY SECOND
SENATE DISTRICT HAS WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ON THIS BILL
OPPORTUNITY IT PRESENTS TO THE
CITY OF NORWALK IN MY DISTRICT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
JONES THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL ALTHOUGH THE IDEA
PRESENTED IN THE BILL I
CERTAINLY DO SUPPORT AND I DO
SUPPORT THE STATE- MAKING
SURPLUS PROPERTY AVAILABLE ON
THE MARKET TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS A FUNCTION OF
THIS BILL ALLOWS THE STATE TO
SELL THAT PROPERTY BELOW MARKET
VALUE. I WOULD REMIND ALL FORTY
SENATORS OF US THAT ALL OF THE
TAX PAYERS AND CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA OWN THIS PROPERTY I
THINK THERE DO A FAIR MARKET
VALUE ON THEIR INVESTMENT AND
IF THERE WAS SOME PROTECTIONS
FOR THE STATE IN THIS IN THAT
CASE I WOULD BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL- BUT AS WRITTEN- I ASK FOR
NO VOTE. THE CENTER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING MANSON ARCH LET
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
ONCE AGAIN I MUST SAY THAT IT
IS FAIR MARKET VALUE ONLY IF
IT'S POSSIBLE AND- GIVEN BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO WITH
THAT I ASK WE REQUEST FOR THE-
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA. MEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BELL I FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG HI DALLY. NO
DODD. I TORONTO. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO FIVE JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE FIVE
MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL. I MONNING
I MORLOCK. ZERO NO NIELSEN NO
HAN I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. I STERN I-
BURKE FIVE WESTGATE WHITE HOUSE
STEVE. I WIENER. WIENER I WILK
NO MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FOR JUST.
GROWTH MORLOCK. FIVE THIRTY NO
SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE WILL TAKE A MOMENT
AND PAUSE SO THAT WE CAN GET
OUR ON CALL LIST READY PLEASE
BE PATIENT AND DO NOT LEAVE
BEFORE.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO LIFT CALLS FIRST
STARTING WITH GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT MENDOZA. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. I'M SORRY SIR
DOLLARS FOR PURPOSE TO RISE
WELL I JUST WANT TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE I DON'T KNOW- NOTE. I TO
KNOW ON THIS ONE I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU CAN SEE ME BACK HERE.
THANK YOU MUCH APPRECIATED.
DALLY I DON'T KNOW. BATES.
GROVE NO MORLOCK. JONES NO
SKINNER. I STERN HI HIGHS
THIRTY TWO FIVE KNOWS FIVE THE
APPOINTMENT. OKAY FIVE THIRTY
THREE KNOWS FIVE THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES. MELENDEZ
MORLOCK. MORALE SKINNER. FIVE
STERN I. FIVE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROSS NO MORE LOCK. NIELSEN
SKINNER I STERN HI FIVE THIRTY
FOUR NO ZERO KNOWS FOR THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED FILE
ITEM EIGHTY TWO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MITCHELL. I
MERLE. SKINNER I STERN HI FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
THE FILE ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELL I SKINNER I STERN HI GUYS
FORTY TWO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT
IS CONFIRMED FILE ITEM EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WELL I FOR JUST.
GROWTH. NO MORE LOCK. SKINNER I
STERN HI. SORRY SENATOR DOLLY.
DALLY I TO KNOW. FIVE THIRTY
ONE NO SEVEN THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON THE FILE
ITEM NINETY THREE SB THREE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. WELL I SKINNER.
HI STERN I. FIVE THIRTY KNOWS
TEN THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE A ONE AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES THE
L. HI FORGES. DALLY HERTZBERG I
JONES. SKINNER I STERN I. FIVE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY TWO AB NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FELL I CABALLERO. I
HERTZBERG. FIVE SKINNER I STERN
AYE AYES TWENTY EIGHT NEWS
TWELVE THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM ONE OH
THREE AB NINE NINE TWO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. I TELL
FIVE CHIANG I DALLY. SKINNER I
STERN I. CENTER BORDERS ON THIS
MEASURE. FORGES I DON'T KNOW.
FIVE THIRTY THREE NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM ONE OH FIVE AB THIRTY
TWENTY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WELL I MELENDEZ NO
SKINNER. I STERN I. BY TWENTY
NINE KNOWS ELEVENTH THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
ONE OF SIX AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES. WELL I DALLY.
GROVE MORLOCK. ZERO NIELSEN.
SKINNER I STERN HI. FIVE THIRTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
TWO AB ELEVEN FORTY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WELL I
MORLOCK. SKINNER I STERN I.
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
WHAT WHAT FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
AB SEVEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
WELL. HI SKINNER I STERN HI.
BUYS FORTINOS ZERO ON THE
URGENCY HIS FORTINOS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES ME TO FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY FOUR AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES WELL I
FORGES. CHIANG I DALY. GROWTH
NO MELENDEZ. MORLOCK NIELSEN NO
SKINNER. I STERN. I WILK. FIVE
THIRTY NEWS FOR THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
FIVE AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THAT FELL I FOR JUST. MORALE.
MORALE I SKINNER I STERN I.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SIX AB NINETEEN FIFTY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELL HI CABALLERO. DODD. DODD I
GALGIANI I GLAZER. GROVE. NO
WAY SO. I SKINNER I STERN I
AMBERG I. IS TWENTY SIX NEWS
TWELVE THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY AB TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WELL I SKINNER. I
STERN HI HIGHS FORTY NINE ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY ONE AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WELL. I JONES. SKINNER
I STERN I. THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY FOUR AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. WELL I FOR JUST.
NO CHIANG. GLAZER. SKINNER I
STERN AYE WILK. I WAS TWENTY
EIGHT NEWS NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTY
FIVE AB THIRTY THREE TWELVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
TELL. FIVE INNER I STERN I.
BUYS FORTY ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
NINE AB TWENTY ONE SIX FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BELL I ENTER. I STERN.
I HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FELL FIVE SKINNER I
STERN AYE AYES FORTY NEW ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY ONE AB TWELVE OH FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELL I SKINNER AYE STERN HI. AS
FOURTEEN OH ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
THREE AB TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
TELL I SKINNER I STERN HI HIGHS
FORTY NEW ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE FORTY FOUR
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN I BATES. WELL I FOR JUST
NO CHIANG I DALLY. HUESO I
JONES. MELENDEZ RUBIO I SKINNER.
I STERN HI FIVE THIRTY TO SIX
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY EIGHT AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WELL I SKINNER THANK
YOU FIVE STERN. BYE BYE CASKEY.
HI HIGHS FORTY NEW ZERO ON THE
URGENCY HIGHS FORTY KNOWS ZERO
ON THE ON THE COUNTER MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELL HI SKINNER. I STERN AYE
WHITE HOUSE THE- HI HIGHS FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WELL
FIVE FORGES. I SKINNER I STERN.
I Y. CASKEY I HIGHS FORTY NEW
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE AB TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. WELL I FOR JUST.
NO CHIANG NO MELENDEZ. NO
NIELSEN. NO SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE WHY CASKEY HI. FIVE TWENTY
NINE THOSE ELEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
I DODD. HI GLAZER. SKINNER I
GOT A GOOD. STERN I WHITE HOUSE
THE HI HIS. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX EIGHTY
NINE OH ONE PLEASE CALL THE
OFFICE AT MEMBERS. SIX NO FOR
JUST. OKAY CHIANG. GROVE HER
TADO. MONNING MORLOCK. STERN I
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WILK. BUT
FOR JUST NOW. FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
IS IT A GALGIANI. THANK YOU
VENTURE MEMBERS I MOVED TO PULL
AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON OFF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR THANK YOU THE
DESK WILL NOTE. I ALSO MOVED TO
PULL AB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN OFF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR THANK YOU CENTER
GALGIANI CENTER BRADFORD. YES
MY PRESIDENT AND I REQUEST THAT
AB A FIVE TWO THREE BY SOMEONE
MEMBER IRWIN BE REMOVED. FROM
THE AN ACTIVE FILES. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD THE DESK WILL
NOTE SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER MADAM
PRESIDENT I MOVE A JOINT RULE
SIXTY ONE AND SIXTY TWO AB
SUSPENDED. FOR THE BUDGET
REVIEW COMMITTEE TO MEET AND
HEAR SOME OF THE BILLS.
861-071-0918 641-865-8060 NINE.
AT EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO ON
THURSDAY AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTH
WITHOUT FOUR DAYS NOTICE IN THE
DAILY FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SENATOR CABALLERO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I REQUEST MY
RIGHTS TO REQUEST WELL NUMBER
IS ENTERED PROBABLY OR ONE
SECOND CENTER NIELSEN. I ASKED
FOR A NO VOTE WE HAVE NOT HAD
TIME TO REVIEW THESE LAST
MINUTE BILLS. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON. THE MOTION IS A
SUSPENDED DRIVER ROLLS CENTER
MITCHELL'S ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE CENTER NIELSEN IS WORK
VOTING ASKING FOR NOVO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES NO WELL I BORDERS NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A- I CHIANG.
DALLY NO DODD. I TORONTO I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE HER TADO
HI JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL
AYE MONNING. MONEY I MORE LOCK
NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO HAN. I
SKINNER I STERN AYE NUMBER FIVE
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WIENER. I
WILK NO IS TWENTY NINE THOSE
TENDERS THE JOINT RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. SENATE COVER YOUR
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO REQUEST FILE NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY NINE ACR ONE TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRADE
BE PULLED FROM CONSENT FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU CENTER CUP CABALLERO THE
DESK WILL KNOW MEMBERS ANYTHING
ELSE. UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. ALL RIGHT THIS IS
THE APPROPRIATE TIME FOR THE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY THAT IS ON
OUR CALENDAR SENATOR MITCHELL.
COLLEAGUES IT IS WITH IMMENSE
SADNESS THAT I STAND AND SHARE
PERHAPS FOR THE FIRST TIME WITH
MANY VIEW THAT A MEMBER OF OUR
ESTEEMED LEGISLATURE THE
HONORABLE GLENMORE. PASSED AWAY
LAST WEEK. HE WAS FIRST ELECTED
IN. NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. END
OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS NO WE KEEP COUNT OF THE
WOMEN WHO WERE ELECTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. WHEN
WAS THE TWENTY SECOND WOMAN
ELECTED TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY. HE WAS THE FOURTH
AFRICAN AMERICAN MEMBER. HE WAS
A PROLIFIC LEGISLATOR WITH OVER
FOUR HUNDRED BILL SIGNED INTO
LAW THROUGH THE COURSE OF HER
CAREER IN THE ASSEMBLY AND MY
COLLEAGUE MY SEAL B. C.
COLLEAGUE FROM GUARDINO WILL GO
INTO GREATER DETAIL ABOUT SOME
OF HER- NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
LEGISLATION AND HER HISTORY
MAKING COMMITTEE THAT SHE
CHAIR. I'M GONNA SPEND A LITTLE
TIME TALKING ABOUT- GLENN MISS
MORE THE LEGISLATOR MENTOR AND
FRIEND. SHE SERVED IN A NUMBER
OF LEADERSHIP CAPACITIES WITH
MANY OF OUR AFFINITY
ORGANIZATIONS. HE WAS A
LEADERSHIP ELECTED LEADERSHIP
OF THE NATIONAL CONFERENCE OF
STATE LEGISLATORS. HE WAS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF AN
ORGANIZATION NOBEL WOMEN THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF BLACK
ELECTED LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S. IN
THE EARLY NINETIES THE
ORGANIZATION NOW BOASTS A
MEMBERSHIP OF ALMOST THREE
HUNDRED BLACK FEMALE STATE
LEGISLATORS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
DUE IN LARGE PART TO MISS
MORRIS TO RELIGION SUPPORT AND
MENTORSHIP. HE TAUGHT IN WAS AN
ACTIVE PARTICIPANT IN THE
CENTER FOR THE AMERICAN WOMEN
AND POLITICS AT RUTGERS
UNIVERSITY NEW JERSEY. WHERE
ONCE AGAIN SHE CONTRIBUTED TO
THEIR MOM MANY YEARS OF
LEADERSHIP TRAINING AND
RESEARCH. AROUND ELECTED WOMEN
AT THE STATE LEVEL. HE WAS AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE OF THE NATIONAL BLACK
CAUCUS OF STATE LEGISLATORS.
WITH CLOSE FRIENDS WITH MANY OF
ITS FOUNDERS IN THAT
ORGANIZATION IN LARGE PART DUE
TO HER MENTORSHIP INTO LINK
YOUR RECRUITMENT. NOW BOASTS A
MEMBERSHIP OF SEVEN HUNDRED
BLACK LEGISLATORS. IN ALL FIFTY
STATEHOUSES ACROSS OUR COUNTRY.
SHE WAS A PAST SPEAKERS
APPOINTEE TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BAR. SHE WAS THE RIGHT
HAND TO BETTY JO TO KOHLI AS A
BOARD MEMBER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESS ASSOCIATION HE
CHAIRED THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION. RUN BY MR
SKIP COOPER. HE WAS A FORMER
HER FIRST ELECTED OFFICE WAS
THAT OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRUSTEE IN LOS ANGELES. TO THE
NATIONAL BOARD OF THE N. DOUBLE
ACP AND FIRST VICE CHAIR OF THE
STATE CONFERENCE OF IN DOUBLE
ACP RUN BY ALICE HOFFMAN. HE
WAS A STRONG SUPPORTER OF LONG
TERM MENTOR OF MINE MANY WOMEN.
WHO ARE ACTIVE IN LA PINE LAW
PACKED THE LOS ANGELES
ALPHANUMERIC WHEN PUBLIC
INSTITUTE. AND THOSE ARE BUT A
FEW OF THE ACTIVITY SHE ENGAGED
IN WHEN SHE LEFT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY BEFORE TERM
LIMITS. TO RUN FOR STATEWIDE
OFFICE SHE RAN FOR SECRETARY OF
STATE AND DID NOT WIN. CLEARLY
MISTER MOORE DIDN'T LET ANY
GRASS GROW UNDER HER FEET AND
HER. WHAT LEGISLATIVE
RETIREMENT HE RAN A GYM A PR
FIRM AND WAS ACTIVELY INVOLVED
IN ADVOCACY AROUND SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT IN THE
UTILITIES. HER MENTORING STYLE
COULD BE BOTH DIRECT AND
INDIRECT. AS SHE STOOD PROBABLY
MAYBE FIVE FOOT ONE ON A GOOD
DAY. OUR VERY OWN DIANNE
GRIFFITH HERE TO. STORY WITH ME
THAT SOUNDS VERY UCH LIKE MISS
MOORE DIçN CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE A FORMER PUBLIC DEFENDER
WAS THE FIRST FEMALE CONSULTANT
TO THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. HE WAS FORCED DOWN
KIND OF IN THE HIERARCHY OF
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS HAVING
BEEN ONE I CERTAINLY KNOW HOW
THAT IS. AND SHE SAID IT WAS
MISS MORE WHO DEMANDED OF THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE BYRON
SHARED THAT. DIANNE BE THE ONE
TO PROVIDE HER WITH HER WEEKLY
BREAK BRIEFINGS. REALLY
ELEVATING DIANE'S RELEVANCE IN
THE EYES OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIR.
I FIRST MET MISS MORRIS THE
CORAL FELL I WAS ASSIGNED TO
HER AND LITTLE DID I KNOW AT
THE TIME BUT SHE KNEW. THAT SHE
AND MY MOTHER HAD BEEN JUVENILE
PROBATION OFFICERS TOGETHER ALL
WHEN I WAS A VERY VERY YOUNG
CHILD. AND HE'S FOLLOWED MY
CAREER AND SUPPORTED ME EVER
SINCE. I HAD THE DISTINCT HONOR
OF SHARING OF LA TIMES FRONT
PAGE PHOTO OF HER ON DECEMBER
SEVENTH OF TWENTY TEN WHEN I
WAS TAKING MY OATH OF OFFICE TO
THE ASSEMBLY. HE'D BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF MY CANDIDACY. I
REALLY ENJOYED LECTURING ME
POINTING UP FROM HER FIVE FOOT
ONE STATUS. HE CAME ON TO THE
FLOOR SHORTLY AFTER WE TOOK.
OUR OATH OF OFFICE TO ASK ME
WHAT COMMITTEES I HAD BEEN
ASKED I HAD ASKED THE SPEAKER
TO APPOINT ME TO. SHE SAID I
KNOW YOU YOUR MOTHER IS A
SOCIAL WORKER YOU ON TRACK FOR
HUMAN SERVICES AND THAT'S NOT
WHERE YOU SHOULD GO. YOU SHOULD
GO FROM OF THE POWER
COMMITTEES. YES MISS MORE OF
COURSE HE CALLED THE KID. SO
SHE WALKED IN THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR I THINK SHE'S COMING TO
CONGRATULATE ME. AND THAT I
JUST TAKEN THE OATH OF OFFICE
TO THE SEAT SHE HAD REPRESENTED
FOR SIXTEEN YEARS. AND SHE
HOPES SIX A FINGER AT ME AND
SAID. I ASK THE SPEAKER. AND HE
TOLD ME YOU HAVE YOU MISTER.
AND I. YOU MADE HIM. MESS AND
DON'T APPOINT YOU THERE. AND
THE PHOTO IN THE LA TIMES IS ME
FALLING OUT LAUGHTER. AND SHE
LAUGHING AS WELL. WE SHARED
MANY MANY MANY LAUGHS FROM THAT
DAY FORWARD. HE LEAVES BEHIND
TO CHERISH HER MEMORY HER
DEVOTED HUSBAND OF TWO YEARS
RON DOBSON SENIOR. THEIR ONLY
CHILD HER SON LITTLE RON IS THE
COLUMN AND LITTLE RON STANDS
ALMOST SIX SIX. GRANDCHILDREN
NIECES AND NEPHEWS A BROTHER IN
LAW. M. A. VAST HOST OF THE
LEGISLATORS FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
MANY CALLS CAME IN OF
LEGISLATORS FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. YOU KNOW MANY STATES
THAT DON'T HAVE TERM LIMITS
LIKE WE DO MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
STILL SERVING IN LEGISLATORS
WHO SERVED WITH CAN'T GO AND
GOT TO KNOW HER THROUGH HER
LEADERSHIP WITHIN SEE A SALE
GOT TO KNOW HER WITH HER
NATIONAL LEADERSHIP AROUND
PUBLIC UTILITIES. EXPRESSING
THEIR ABSOLUTE UTTER SHOCK AND
DISMAY AND DEEPENED PROFOUND
SADNESS. HER FRIENDS HER
MENTEES HER HEY KIDS KIDS WE'LL
ALL MISS MISS HER DEEPLY. HE
HAD A CORE GROUP OF WOMEN JOY
ATKINSON WHO WAS WORK WITH HER
IN JUVENILE PROBATION AND THEN
LETS HER DISTRICT DIRECTOR WHO
WAS STILL CONSULTING WITH HER
JIM COMMUNICATIONS NOW AND THE
STATE CORE GROUP ALICE HUFFMAN
OF WOMEN ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY.
WHO LOOK TO GLENN. AS THE
BRIDGE SHE WAS THE BRIDGE
BETWEEN. LEGISLATORS OF A PAST
ERA. AND LEGISLATORS TODAY. HE
WASN'T A NATIVE OF LOS ANGELES
HE MOVED TO LA AT THE AGE OF
FIVE BUT SHE KNEW LA LIKE THE
BACK OF HER HAND AND SHE LOVED
THE CITY OF ANGELS DEEPLY. IT
IS WITH DEEP DEEP SADNESS IN A
TRUE SENSE OF LOSS OF A MENTOR
SHIP AND KIND OF A NORTH STAR
GUIDE. THAT I ASK THAT YOU JOIN
ME AND MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
JOURNEY IN MEMORY. OF FORMER
ASSEMBLYWOMAN OF THE FORTY
SEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. MISS
GLENN MORE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
TO RISE IN ASKS THAT THIS BODY
ADJOURN AND THE MEMO OF MISS
MORE. A INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS MIKE
FROM LH SERVED NOT ONLY AS AN
AMAZING LEGISLATURE. LEGISLATOR
BUT AS A- MENTOR AND A FRIEND
TO ME AND MANY OTHERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION. I
REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME I.
THOUGHT ELECTED OFFICE IT WAS
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT FOUR
WATER BOARD SEAT. AND I WAS
RUNNING AROUND LOOKING FOR
SOMEONE TO CALL ELECTED
OFFICIALS FOR SUPPORT. AN OUT
OF BLUE MISS MOORE WAS THE
FIRST INDIVIDUAL TO NOT ONLY
ENDORSED ME BUT SAID COME TO MY
OFFICE AND HE SUPPORTED ME
FINANCIALLY AS WELL I LOVE
TELLING THE STORY OF THE
BIGGEST. CHECK I'D EVER
RECEIVED AND I WAS BLOWN AWAY
BY HER. GENEROSITY BUT MISS
MOORE'S LEGACY HERE AND THIS
LEGISLATURE WILL LIVE ON AS MY
COLLEAGUE STATED SHE PASSED
OVER FOUR HUNDRED BILLS AND I
CHALLENGE ANY OF US HERE WHO'LL
DO THE TWELVE YEARS OR EVEN
POSSIBLY THE FOURTEEN YEARS
EVEN MATCHED HALF OF THOSE
NUMBERS THAT SHE GOT SIGNED
INTO LAW. BUT TO THE CRAWLERS
THE MOST IMPACTFUL THAT ARE
STILL HAVING AFFECTS NOT ONLY
YEAR ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BUT ACROSS THE NATION WAS. HER
BILL THAT CREATED LIFELINE
TELEPHONE LIFELINE WHO IS KNOWN
AND STILL KNOWN AS THE MORE
LIFE LINE NO. THAT PROVIDED
AFFORDABLE PHONE SERVICES FOR
POOR AND SENIOR CITIZENS IT IS
STILL A TOOL THAT IS USED TODAY
IS STILL A MEASURE THAT WE ARE
CONTINUALLY. ARE SUPPORTING AN
ACID TO BE. EXPANDED UPON BUT
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT BRIDGING
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE MISS MOORE
WAS THE FIRST ONE TO REALLY
TALK ABOUT THE NEED OF ACCESS
FOR THOSE AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND LOW INCOME. BUTANOTHER PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT HAS GROWN AND BY LEAPS AND
BOUNDS WAS EIGHTY THIRTY SIX.
OF SEVENTY EIGHT. ALL WHICH IS
NOW KNOWN AS JOURNAL ORDER ONE
FIFTY SIX. IT CREATED THE
SUPPLIER CONTRACTING. AND
PROCUREMENT FOR MINORITY OWNED
WOMEN OWNED AND DISABLED
VETERANS AND IS EXPANDED NOW TO
ADD LGBT OVER THE NUMBER OF
YEARS DALLAS PASSED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AND NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR UTILITIES WERE SPENDING
LESS THAN A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS. WITH MINORITY OWNED OR
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES TODAY
THEY WILL EXCEED OVER TWELVE
DISTRIBUTED TO MISS MORE AND
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO KNOW MY
POLITICAL CAREER I. CONSTANTLY
ADVOCATED. FOR THE EXPENSIVE
GENERAL ORDER ONE FIFTY SIX IT
WAS BALLOT LANGUAGE THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO PUT INTO SB ONE A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO A BIG AT
THE GAS TAX. FOR ON HIGHWAY
TRANSPORTATION BILL AND IT WAS
THAT LANGUAGE THAT WE ANSWERED
IT WAS SIMILAR LANGUAGE THAT WE
INSERTED INTO SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY FOR OUR INSURANCE
INDUSTRY TWO YEARS AGO BECAUSE
OF MRS MORE LEADERSHIP. AND AS
MY COLLEAGUE STATED SHE WAS.
ALWAYS CHALLENGING ME WHEN I
GOT TO THE LEGISLATURE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE AND I WAS GIVEN
THE CHEER OF UTILITIES AND
COMMERCE IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
MISS MORE COULD HAVE BEEN ANY
PROBLEM. AND SHE WAS QUICK TO
CALL ME AND CONSTANTLY GIVE ME
ADVICE AS TO WHAT I SHOULD AND
SHOULD NOT DO AS CHAIR OF
UTILITY COMMERCE AND SHE WAS
QUICK TO MAKE SURE THAT I WAS
SITTING ON SOME PANELS
SOMEWHERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ADVOCATING FOR THE
EXPANSION OF GENERAL ORDER ONE
FIFTY SIX OR CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE OR MAKING SURE.
OUR UTILITIES WERE WAS
AFFORDABLE AND ADVOCATING FOR
ALL THOSE THINGSTHAT SHE TRULY
BELIEVE IN AND SHE CHAMPION.
THE YEARS BUT- WHAT STICKS OUT
MOST FOR ME IS THE DIVERSITY
THAT YOU SEE IN THIS INDUSTRY
TODAY. BECAUSE THIRTY SOMETHING
YEARS AGO WILL MISS MORE WHICH
CHAIR OF UTILITIES AND COMMERCE
WHERE SHE SERVED FOR TWELVE
YEARS. SHE DREW A LINE IN THE
SAND. BECAUSE THIRTY FOUR YEARS
AGO. THIS IS A WHITE MALE
DOMINATED INDUSTRY AS IT
RELATES TO THE REPRESENTATION
IN A LOGGING OF THE INSURANCE.
YOU TELL THE INDUSTRY. AND SHE
DREW A LINE IN THE SAND AND
SAYS IF YOU'RE COMING TO LOBBY
ME AS- HERE OF UTILITIES YOU
MUST. WHITE HOUSE MINORITIES
ANY MYSELF WOMEN. SO EVERY
MINORITY TODAY WHETHER YOU'RE
IN A HOUSE. OR CONTRACT
LOBBYIST WHO'S A PERSON OF
COLOR OR WOMAN OR GRATITUDE
THANKS TO MISS MORE THE W. FOUR
MEANS OF THE WORLD THE CAROL
BILL HUNDREDS OF THE WORLD THE
MISSY JOHNSONS OF THE WORLD THE
P. HERNANDEZ IS OF THE WORLD
THEY WOULD NOT. PROBABLY EXISTS
TODAY. IF IT WASN'T FOR MISS
MORE OR THE HIRING INTERNALLY I
WORK AT A UTILITY. BEFORE
COMING HERE AND IT WAS BECAUSE
OF MRS MORE STRONG ADVOCACY FOR
DIVERSITY IN THE UTILITY SPACE
THAT WE SEE THE DIVERSITY THAT
STANDS HERE TODAY SO. IT IS
WITH GREAT SORROW BUT GREAT
PRIDE THAT I A JOURNEY IN HER
MEMORY BUT INDIVIDUAL AGAIN WHO
HELPED SHAPE MY LIFE. NOT ONLY
POLITICALLY BUT PERSONALLY WHO
WAS ALWAYS AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID
THAT GUIDING STAR MAKING SURE I
DID THE RIGHT THING AND WHEN I
DID SEE WAS QUICK TO PICK UP
THE PHONE AND CALL ME. AND LET
ME KNOW IF SHE WAS DISAPPOINTED
IN SOMETHING I DIDN'T DO OR
SOMETHING I SHOULD HAVE DONE.
AND SHE WAS A STRONG COURAGEOUS
ADVOCATE FOR ALL THOSE THINGS
THAT. WE ALL SHOULD HOLD TO
REPRESENT ANY ATTEMPT FIVE AS
AN ELECTIVE COURSES SYOSSET WE
TURN IN THE MEMORY OF. WHEN
MORE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
OTHER MEMBERS THAT WANT TO
SPEAK SENATOR NIELSEN IS FIRST
KATHLEEN AND THEN. NUMBER AGAIN
THEN YOURSELF SENATOR NIELSEN
SENATE PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE. I TO.
GRIEVE THE PASSING. OF WHEN.
RIGHT COLLEAGUES FROM LOS
ANGELES MENTIONED TO ME EARLIER
IN THE WEEK- LAST WEEK THAT-
SHE HAD PASSED IT WAS KIND OF A
SHOCK. DID I GOTTEN USED TO
GLENN ALWAYS BEING AROUND. KNOW
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT WE CAME TO
THE LEGISLATURE THE SAME YEAR
SHE WAS I THINK AT THAT TIME
ONE OF ONLY MAYBE TEN OR SO
WOMEN WHO'D EVER BEEN ELECTED
TO THE ASSEMBLY. AND THAT SAME
YEAR DIANNE WATCH BECAME THE
SECOND WOMAN. EVER ELECTED TO
THE STATE SENATE. LATER THAN
THERE WERE MANY IF YOU SEE
THOSE PICS NOW GROWN ENORMOUS.
BUT GLENN AND HER STATURE HAS
BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED. I ALWAYS SAW
HER OF THE WORD THAT BEST
DESCRIBE HER PERSONALITY WAS
PART. AND BRILLIANT. AND I
FOUND OUT AND SHE WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST PEOPLE IN THE
ASSEMBLY THAT I BEGAN TO WORK
WITH AS A CONSERVATIVE SENATOR
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SHE
BEING AN URBAN LEGISLATOR. FROM
LOS ANGELES. BUT WE FOUND THAT
WE HAVE MUCH IN COMMON. AND
OVER THE DECADES WE DID A LOT
OF THINGS TOGETHER CO AUTHORING
BILLS. AND WHEN SHE LEFT THE
LEGISLATURE. I ALWAYS LOOK
FORWARD TO WHEN SHE MIGHT POP
UP AGAIN AND SHOULD SHOW UP IN
THE CHAMBERS AND I ALWAYS RUN
BACK AND IN THOSE DAYS YOU
COULD DO THE A BRAZO WITHOUT
GETTING IN TROUBLE- AND I WE
pALWAYS HAD BIG HUG BIG SMILES
AND HER PERSONALITY JUST NEVER
CHANGED. BUT SHE WAS AN
INDIVIDUAL WHEN MORE WHO DID
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THIS
INSTITUTION. NOT JUST THE
LEGACY OF THE LEGISLATION. THAT
MY COLLEAGUES MUSTANG VERSUS
CHAU APTLY ACKNOWLEDGED. BUT
THE COUNTRY CONTRIBUTION TO THE
CONDUCT OF BUSINESS IN THIS
HOUSE HOW SHE DEALT WITH OTHER
MEMBERS IN BOTH HOUSES. VERY
GRACIOUS VERY SHARP VERY CANDID
WITH YOU ABOUT ADVICE AS TO HOW
THINGS NEEDED TO GO IF YOU HAD
A BILL IN HER COMMITTEE IT
WASN'T JUST UP OR DOWN SHE
WOULD. TALK WITH YOU ABOUT.
THERE WAS A CHANCE TO AMENDED
IN A MANNER ACCEPTABLE THEN WE
WOULD ALWAYS BE ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER. AND AGAIN AS WE
PROCEED NOW. AND I CAN FEEL HER
PRESENCE EVEN WITH US HERE
TODAY. STANDING WHEN MORE
ALWAYS BE LOOKING BACK AT THE
CHAMBER TO SEE WHEN STANDING
THERE. AND GOING BACK TO GIVE
HER A HUG. SHE IS A WOMAN WHO
MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE. THEY
SHOULD BE WITH THE LORD AND OUR
FAMILY OR FAMILY BE COMFORTED.
NIELSEN SENATOR UMBERG. MEMBERS
ARISES SOMEONE WHO SERVED IN
THE ASSEMBLY WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MORE. THIRTY YEARS AGO
WHEN I CAME TO THE ASSEMBLY I
WAS THE ONLY DEMOCRAT ELECTED
FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND SUITABLE
A LOST SOUL AND I WASN'T HERE
LONG AND ASSEMBLY WOMAN MORE
INVITED ME TO COME TO DINNER
AND A MOVIE WITH A MARGUERITE
ARCHIE HUDSON THERESA HUGHES.
AND BARBARA LEAD THE FOUR OF
THEM AND I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
INVITED ME TO COME BECAUSE THEY
WANTED SOME COMIC RELIEF OR
THEY WERE EDUCATING ME OR WAS
LIKE BRING A LOST PUPPY TO A
PICNIC. BUT THEY BROUGHT ME
ALONG TO MOVIE AND DINNER AND I
REMEMBER THAT SHE TOOK ME UNDER
HER WING AND SHE STARTED TO
EDUCATE ME ABOUT THE WAYS THE
LEGISLATURE VERY DEDICATED
SMART HARD DRIVING. BUT I
REMEMBER THAT PERSONAL TOUCH IN
TWO OR THREE DINNER SHE BROUGHT
ME TO WITH THAT SAME GROUP
THANK YOU FOR THE SAME REASONS.
AND THEY WOULD DEBATE
LEGISLATION. VERY HEATED. BUT
THE MOST HEATED DEBATE I RECALL
WAS ONE NIGHT AFTER A MOVIE
WHERE THEY GOT QUITE ANIMATED
AND THAT WAS OVER DENZEL DENZEL
OR WESLEY. AND I DON'T REMEMBER
WHICH SIDE WHEN WAS ON BUT
EVERYONE WAS VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT THAT ISSUE. AND SO I RISE
BECAUSE- SHE LEFT A MARK SHE
LEFT A MARK ON THE LEGISLATURE
SHE LEFT A MARK ON ME. MAY SHE
REST IN POWER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER AMBERG CENTER
GALGIANI. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I HAD THE BENEFIT OF
HER GRACIOUS GENEROSITY AND
ADVICE AND COUNSEL WHEN I HAD
AUTHORED THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
BEHIND A YEAR LATER WE RECEIVED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING AND THE PROGRAM DID NOT
HAVE A SMALL BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PROGRAM AT ALL AND
IS A NEW ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I
KNEW VERY LITTLE ABOUT THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAM AND
SHE GAVE ME THE HISTORY AND
POINTED ME TO PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION HELP ME TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT GOING FORWARD AND
WHILE IT WAS NOT THE
LEGISLATURE THAT ACTUALLY
CRAFTED THE FINAL PRODUCT
SENATOR KERN PRICE WHO WAS IN
THE SENATE AT THE TIME AND
MYSELF WE HAD WE EACH HAD BILLS
WE WERE DOING WORKSHOPS ACROSS
THE STATE. AND WE HELP GUIDE
THAT PROCESS THAT NOW IS IN
PLACE FOR THE AUTHORITY WITH A
THIRTY PERCENT- MINORITY- SMALL
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAM IN
PLACE AND I LARGELY THANK HER
FOR BEING SO GENEROUS TO WORK
WITH WITH ME AT THAT TIME THANK
YOU. BIG CENTER GALGIANI AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR KIND
WORDS AND SENATE MITCHELL
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU BRING HER
NAME FORWARD. IF THERE IS NO
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES WHAT A WONDERFUL
TRIBUTE TO AN INCREDIBLE WOMAN
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GOING MORE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT IT'S A GOOD
WAY TO END OUR DAY- AND SHE WAS
A MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
IN THIS TIME WE HAVEN'T BEEN
DOING ADJOURNING MEMORIES BUT
THIS WAS SO APPROPRIATE THAT WE
PAY THE RESPECT. THAT IS DUE
SOMEONE- THAT CREATED QUITE A
LEGACY SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
OUR COLLEAGUES- WE WILL.
RECONVENE OR COME BACK TOGETHER
NOT TOMORROW TOMORROW WILL BE
CHECK IN BUT ON WEDNESDAY
AUGUST TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWENTY
AT TEN AM HAVE A GOOD EVENING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM THE SENATE WILL BE
ADJOURNED AND WE WILL RECONVENE
WEDNESDAY AT TEN AM HAVE A NICE
EVENING MEMBERS.